peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand je crois pas
[Musique]
on
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle est sinon mon café
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors si nokia
non mais bon dieu mais y'a personne dans
cette baraque surprise voilà le café du
grand vizir série bien chaud par la
sultane numéro un et avec de la brioche
ouais ça va on ne peut pas les mais au
contraire je viens de faire mon jogging
cette brume bleuté aussi les tendances
petit matin tu ne peux pas savoir comme
c'était beau enfin non mais j'espère que
tu as rencontré personne fassi à
l'écureuil ça m'a donné l'idée d'un
petit pont en bas toi alors les petits
plus ils deviennent comme ça absurde je
quitterai la compagnie ça te faudra
comme si j'avais le temps forts heures
c'est toi qui s'arrête il est gêné la
nation sur ma lancée et qu'est ce qu'ils
foutent lrt de laisser je vais
t'expliquer robert c'est la communion de
la petite baie enfin me dis pas que tu
leur as encore donner un genre de
plongée nord qu'une semaine
ouais ben au portugal c'est pas la porte
à compter enfin si je paye des d'un v6
est pourri balle de service
c'est pas beau de ma femme s'habille
tout brûle les gens n'auraient pas pour
une fois et puis j'aime bien me
retrouver seul de temps en temps dans ma
cuisine
j'en profite pour changer le plastique
des placards que recense et autres
confitures
je fais le bilan de la casse tout en
raison des petits pourraient enfin sonné
mi-temps rôle ni ta place en fait les
malins plus jeunes afin de n'oublier pas
mais je n'oublie pas revers je le répète
des bâtons réveil je suis même plus
jeunes
je suis mort du jour je suis valeur
refuge
au fait ne suis je réellement comme un
jeu que voici peu laisse pas mélanger
mais qu'est ce que t'as suzanne ce matin
je sais pas je sais pas je te trouve
bien primesautière je le prends comme un
compliment
bah tu as tort dans ta position est
patent et grand mère oui ça aussi faux
que je me la pète dès le matin elles
suivront mais ce grand mère je suis trop
molle cervelle de moineau et alors tout
le monde ne peut pas être aveugle
et oui ça s'est bien passé c'est bien
vrai bonjour quand même un bon jour je
t'ai pas dit bonjour non à ben alors
bonjour
ouais
tu as bien dormi barras et ça s'est bien
passé hier soir avec son acheteur a le
mot ça s'est bien passé ça s'est bien
passé à ce que c'est une bonne mine à
faire pour commencer par les distraire
alors je les emmenais à lyon on a dîné
chez chapiteau ça c'est terminé on bat
la boum
1 il paraît qu'elle est jolie fille
omama bouvenot oui j'aurais aimé
tu me emmènera une fois t'es folle enfin
c'est pas ta place
ah ben non plus anciens
alors c'est par la place à la cuisine
c'est pas ma place de la bourse
d'athènes à faire mais arrête de poser
des questions idiotes
tu n'as pas ton cul mais pour moi la
paysanne
mais tu sais ce médecin a dit écoute moi
je sais ce que j'ai à faire je te trouve
de plus en plus nerveux il irrite à 23
c'est la paix de nogent de diriger une
usine de 300 oreiller de se bagarrer
quotidiennement et que le comité
d'entreprise avec des syndicats
classiques sur aia qui est polyvalent
alors je te parle pas de la tva ni du
blocage des prix mis les nouveaux
décrets qui sort tous les jours y
compris ceux de la veille ni de la
garantie de l'emploi ni la crise du
pétrole
alors là je te le demande tu crois que
c'est la fête mais papa 18 jours le même
show et on va du temps de ton père
c'était du gâteau
d'ailleurs lorsqu'il l'a bien mené son
affaire
heureusement que je t'ai épousée et que
j'ai redressé la situation parce que
sans ça vous en seriez votto et oui tu
as apporté tour dynamisme je n'apportais
que l'usiné de pâtes
mais ce qui veut dire rien sinon que
dans une corbeille de mariée une usine
c'est mieux qu'une pelle à tarte en
métal argenté en café brienonnais merci
tu sais que laurent est ici à bord bas
depuis fin mai il y en avait hier soir
alors il débarque comme celle il sent
pas venir on devine pourquoi il est
vraiment belle lutte finale
maintenant je t'ai déjà dit que j'étais
pressé il est vu pour mon anniversaire
ton anniversaire tu avais oublié et non
non pas du tout c'est cette conne de
nadège tu as oublié de le rappeler dans
ce traité a autre chose à quoi construit
baubay coup tu m'excuseras mais alors
aujourd'hui je suis débordé alors j'ai
vraiment pas le temps d'aller choisir un
cadeau bon voilà achète toi ce que tu
voudras puis bon bah tu me verras la
note
sois gentil quand tu verras l'euro ce
soir fermé fin avec lui chaque fois
qu'ils viennent ouverture va t'en
empêcher
il faut qu'il dise des choses blessantes
ouais enfin j'ai un fils un seul fils et
un bon à rien alors il est diplômé de
sens crible paul fort c'est minable lui
dans l'avenir était tout tracé à la tête
de cette fusée enfin tout le monde n'a
pas envie de fabriquer des parapluies
6,18 toi même de nos jours ce n'est pas
la fête a évidemment évidemment alors
dès qu'il s'agite office alors là bas
que tu veux te taire un pool foudre on
écoute les nouvelles soient gentils
alors tais-toi management le climat
social s'est levé on utilise plusieurs
points jeunes en province les ordres de
grève ont été lancés par les syndicats
nous avons demandé à notre habileté de
ce journal le député communiste maurice
babin avait marqué plus que celui de
faire le point sur la situation
tant qu'on aille à vélo tard des mesures
radicales s'imposent tant faveur des
travailleurs en foutez moi vous êtes
inspirons de l'autre le mélange peut pas
se noyer ou signés charrière jusqu'à
quand durera continue à toutes les mères
j'ai dans mon usine
cette fois ça n'est pas toi qu'il vise
personnel dijon et tout ça parce que
c'est d'apporter à 25 ans avoue tournoi
cet agitateur pour les dix tours elle
était déjà très fort les vibrations ça
pouvait attendre alors un camionneur
pape lui j'en ai rien à [ __ ] je te les
biens et montréal coup de patte dans le
plus primé coup de poing dans la figure
c'est toi qui a reçu deux dents de
cassées tu n'étais pas bon avoir
beaucoup chez riber est en tout cas ça
m'a permis de le faire condamner pour
coups et blessures et hop
alors après ça qu'est ce qui pourrait
faire l'autre à part de la politique ça
lui a pas trop mal réussi l'on dirait
quand je pense qu'il est notre mère et
notre député aubin chercher il n'y a pas
de jour posé ce sale poko dans les
pattes alors toi tu voudrais que je
pense à ton anniversaire
mais moi je ne veux rien avait rien du
tout que tu sois simplement bonne dose
autant de bonne humeur et vanille comme
pas tant que maryse babar
sur ce département et alors suzanne moi
je te le dis ce pays est foutu
comment peux tu être aussi pessimiste
avec un si beau soleil en haut puis
cuicui épouse 10 oiseaux chantent un
tribun suppan oiseaux et vous vous dites
aujourd'hui la ville et autoroute ne
reste que ça intéresse mais pas le coeur
et ce soir nous serons tous réunis en
famille autour d'une table et cueillir
chandelle je vais tout préparer moi même
avec amour en moi je trouve que c'est ça
le bonheur
embêtant mais le 6ème c'est une
contrainte 1 après tout c'est ton
anniversaire phone ou un petit poème tu
ne réussis pas au dessert allez ne
tenons pas de moi durant trouver des
jeunes et jolies pas déjeuner jean et
wet le préfet pour mettre au point cette
histoire de cannes photo je suis encore
bien bloqué leur avance à g l'inspecteur
du palais sur les panneaux je ne sais
pas robin au nom de dieu en veux tu m'as
mis en retard et les histoires de bonne
femme la météo fait trop robert un de
ces jours sans mais ça va jouer un sale
tour
attention attention
ouais non je dis attention attention tu
n'as plus 20 tours ben ça doit bien de
me dire ça m'a post usa noah qui vient
de prendre un an de plus je viens
toujours le mot qui fait plaisir
bon à propos des gens qui comme moi
n'ont pas encore quelques dates en
franchise de nos comptables passé sur
les frais généraux mais fais moi un
petit sourire avant de partir oui bon
enfin aujourd'hui je ne peux rien
refuser mieux ça c'est remboursé par la
sécurité sociale
j'arrive là il joue et de clients de
rudy bon voyons épaule d'agneau 68
francs
rognon de veau 92 francs il était par un
peu caoutchouteux faut que j'en fasse la
remarque au boucher parce qu'à ce prix
là il tombe
épicerie mon ami l'écureuil était là ce
matin il m'a fait un clin d'oeil et j'ai
dit à deux mois ferme à man au mot chéri
e
j'espère je suis première tout le
souhaite mais ils n'auront père vient de
le faire
enfin sa manière est déjà parti est moi
qui voulais prendre mon petit déjeuner
avec lui décèle matin il n'est pas très
bon poil
tu crois que ça ira mieux ce souhait je
l'espère je suis une incorrigible
optimiste bien on se connaît tellement
bien chaud avec de la brioche et de la
confiture de coings way ma préférée tu
te tapes oui voilà halloween ne quittez
pas oui allô allô oui allô oui
ah oui bonjour oui oui bonjour madame la
directrice oui oui pardon pardon que je
préside le banquet des anciens du
troisième âge
oh oui oh je suis très honoré mais mais
à quel titre junior j'espère
ah le chanoine s'est cassé le col du
fémur ça c'est désolant
écoutez alors j'essaierai de remplacer
un au pied levé ces gens se dire ah oui
en bas vous savez je m'en fais des
chaînes une vraie petite fête
entendu en vol oui oh oui oh oui oh oui
oh la la région
encore joyeux moments en perspective
excuses marché regardez moi où je ne
trouve pas très bonne mine
tu manges bien à paris mais oui maman
joue pas ça des pizzas dans quelle
horreur le travail c'est mon temps mais
à peu près sûr je peux tenir ce poste
d'assistant musée guimet aweys est un
bon job non je suis bien heureuse
pourtant tu as toujours ce que tu
voulais continue sans écouter personne
mais surtout à toi ne te presse pas de
te marier mais pourquoi me dit tu sors
de parce que je sais à quel point tu
aimes ton indépendance alors tu as tout
le temps 1
et le jour où tu rencontreras la
merveille des merveilles mais je
t'arrête moment je ne sais pas si c'est
la merveille des merveilles mais je
rencontrais une fille justement et ma
foi on pense sérieusement mariage tous
les deux non c'est pas possible
oui allô oui allô oui
ah oui mon jeu que ce gars me chaoui
c'est galichon oui oui le chef de la
fanfare il tombe toujours à contretemps
ce média alors allez-y calleja vous
écoute monsieur du show et les idéaux
toi tu es sûr que tu ne t'emballe pas
plus rapidement que ça fait trois mois
qu'on est ensemble au jeu pas me dire
que tu es choqué au l affiche le temps
avec un père de trois enfants qui
marilyn la plus gracieuse de nommage
aurait et alors qu'est ce que ça nous
fasse
il faut absolument lui trouver une
remplaçante
si notre parade du 14 juillet 1 déjà que
patricia quatre ans à 13h30
allons messieurs richard non non bien
sûr
je ne peux pas la remplacer oui je ne
peux vraiment pas en place et tout le
monde ya déjà chanoine que c'est assez
le fait qu'à sa tête
bon ça serait trop là vous expliquer
alors débrouillez-vous parce que moi
aussi j'ai mes problèmes allaient
bonjour chez vous on a marre avec les
majorettes du pipeline et de pavillons
nom déjà
enfin maman au mont chine
tu es amour va se dire que ça colle bien
entre nous qu'est ce qu'elle fait dans
la vie l'heureux électorale des chiffres
comme toi des inscriptions sibérienne
non elles ce sont des partitions lé
pianiste elle prépare le conservatoire
et elle est très douée ont manqué
justement d'artistes dans la famille le
piano après enfin servir je pense a été
raccordé celui là alors oui moi tu la
connais depuis longtemps je connais
depuis six mois
j'ai fait sa connaissance dans le train
quand je suis venu à alors elle est
alors l disi melia jamais vécu elle a
été levée à paris par sa grand-mère à je
comprends très bien
ah oui et les parents c'est qui mais
marc ysaye les marquises et les
marquises et ça me dit quelque chose
la pâtisserie de la place de la
cathédrale que le monde est petit je me
souviens chaque dimanche en son temps à
metz nous nous arrêtons pencher la
spécialité de la maison
la bombe glacée ils ont une fille
marquise et floriane fleuries 1 c'est
ravissant comme l'on sait pas banal mais
c'est ravissant si elle est aussi jolie
que l'était sa mère je me souviens de la
belle manne à marquise est trop no1 sa
caisse
j'ai pas comment les toulousains taille
aussi avec pas fermée chez les messieurs
et toujours si bien coiffée mon dieu
qu'elle était bien coiffé la pauvre elle
est morte électrocutée par un séchoir
électrique alors tu veux épouser la
fille marc ysaye écoute je crois que
rien ne préfèrerais moi je suis pas
contre alors ça simplifierait toi le com
mais c'est évident verdict est pas là je
suis pas là ah oui bonjour chers amis et
c'est la préfète enchères amis j'étais
confuse de vous faire choux les grands
plein d'autres soir mes yeux je te
confie tout faire louper grand chelem
autres soirs mais figurez-vous j'avais
pris un valet de coeur pour le roi de
pique
aa oui à ça quand on joue aux cartes de
centimes
ce sont des erreurs coûteuses et qu elle
est d'un radar oui
bien sûr un mardi entendu entendu je
mettrai mes lunettes au marché rami au
revoir à les voir bon à toi il faudrait
tout de même en parler à ton père abattu
par le fait que j'ai l'intention d'en
parler a pas parlé dès la première
occasion encore je vais pas lui demander
la permission 1
s'il est d'accord tant mieux s'il l'est
pas on se passera de son consentement
comme de toute façon je n'attends rien
de lui on boit on a essayé on connaît ce
mal parler essayons que les choses
s'arrangent de la type e pourquoi web
de quelle façon j'ai pas encore trouvé
mais mal non plus mais moi je sais
toujours pas ce que tu veux auj envie de
prendre ces gouttes
je l'aimais pourtant bien en évidence
devant du médecin à 10,1 s'il ne fait
pas attention il finira par maintes
étapes à la mode maman à paypal et à
n'ont pas pu un infarctus
alors oui alors à m'amuser nadège vous
êtes là bon alors est-ce que vous avez
vu mon mari et l'a alors d'études
spatiales dit qu'il passe à la maison va
lâcher préfet il a envie de prendre ces
gouttes
oui il va vous envoyons bol ben vous en
avez l'habitude comme moi alors je
compte sur vous sans faute un merci à
marc cherry
bon anniversaire aux petites filles oh
la belle madame million un oui je viens
de là gagner pour toi et bien matinal
j'allais déposer les enfants à l'école
tu feras les connais les gens ils te
remettra ce soir en grande cérémonie un
dessin qu'il a fait spécialement pour
toi ô et qu'est ce que ça représente des
terroristes avec des mitraillettes
c'est trop mignon quant à patrick il te
réserve une imitation de caunes us open
a dit moi chérie tu as des nouvelles de
son mari mais arnaud m'a téléphoné ce
matin de toronto il en appelle d'autres
a fallu pas ce faire le voyageur de
commerce et moi aussi je le bats jamais
trop peu de gens se déplacent mango avec
les gosses comme c'est commode qui les
garderai ma petite fille que tu leur
laisses kiev tout ce qu'ils valent or il
me semble que je vous ai pas si mal
élever ton frère et wafa et puis tu m'as
vent l'éducation des enfants c'est moi
qui m'en charge si tu veux bien a en
revanche il faut absolument que tu me
soutiennent j'ai décidé de faire une
grande offensive auprès de papa oui
alors je suis pas sûr sous un bon jour
et bien tant pis j'ai déjà trop attendu
ce que ça fait cinq ans je suis marié
papa était bien content qu'ils aient
vous à venir sa fille baronne ça donnait
des quartiers de noblesse à ces
parapluies
mais qu'est ce qu'il nous a donné en
échange de promesses mais il serait
temps qu'il les mette à exécution
nous devions nous installer à paris il
papa allait ouvrir un bureau de vente
dont arnaud celle direct accord chéri
mais la conjoncture économique non ce
conflit n'a jamais été des plus gros
chiffre d'affaires dans la vérité c'est
il veut que nous soyons là sous sa botte
des esclaves
arnaud me dit que ce n'était même pas la
peine d'avoir épousé la fille du patron
pour être traité comme un sous fifre
quand tu sais comment ça m'en vouloir je
le sens bien ce des tâches de moi si tu
veux que je te dise
depuis combien de temps il m'a pas fait
la moue de nombreux noms mais je te dise
mais qu'est ce que j'entends le baron
délaisse ma petite forme
tiens tu es là toi crois-tu toute ma
petite famille réunie autour de moi pour
m'aider à souffler les bougies wiba sans
fard ni mais on le gardera une part de
gâteau à ce moment c'est trop a changé
de coiffure oui pourquoi tu n'aimes pas
mais si au contraire s'est adouci le
visage rond frère me fait un compliment
je n'en crois pas mes heures réélire
mais entend rester sur cette bonne
impression logo tu aller faire un tour
du côté du chenil non pourquoi on
attendait rien à voir ses petits
il portait de ces chiots plus adorables
les uns que les autres lacunes titre de
ford ou d'une vidéo comme tout bon voir
ça
ap ap marc cherry oui pour en revenir à
ce que nous disions tout à l'heure il ne
faut pas s'alarmer outre mesure au sujet
ton mari il y as chez les couples les
plus unis des temps morts rythme des
rapports intimes se ralentit par
intermittence i
et puis ça repart nous ça ne repart pas
tu en sais quelque chose
comment depuis combien d'années faites
vous sans bras par papa et toi tu sais
je n'aime pas parler de ce genre de
choses joué à boulogne depuis la
naissance de l'europe apparaît pas dû
souvent trop de visite la nuit d'obtenir
pas aller dis moi la vérité quand papa
s'est il comporté avec toi en mari pour
la dernière alors là si tu crois que je
tiens ce genre de compte alors
seule la maison de suffisent je vais te
dire il ya autre chose que le sexe dans
la vie ma petite fille oui quoi à toi tu
tiens de mois on en voit pas passer des
choses tellement tout un journal usine
quand il rentre le soir tu as peu
fatigué et bien pour ta trompé il allait
parler joël je te défonce que 17 ont
fait c'est par lui que je critique c'est
toi tu as tout accepter tout tu fais
semblant de ne rien voir
tu prend des airs détachés à la fonction
l'insee j'ai toujours été imperméable en
affrontant puis j'ai ma maison j'ai ma
famille j'ai ma tapisserie j'ai mon
jogging
j'ai des petits poèmes mon ami
l'écureuil et la somme afin d'enfermer
le vit à te pousse une vie
et satie fitou sens mais tu veux dire
que les journaux ne sont pas assez de
mal et elle était heureuse de oui je
suis heureuse
d'abord je vais décider une fois pour
toutes alors tu vois c'est pas moi je ne
veux pas de cette vie là je ne vais pas
finir comme toi entre les ventes de
charité le dispensaire la brique je la
préfère la corvée les dîners de chasse
hiatus est ce que tu es maman non ma
chérie une potiche je te remercie m
alors je dis non c'est vrai tu le fais
exprès c'est pourtant assez dit de pas
par keita voiture devant la porte du car
voilà tu me retourne je me suis arrêtée
juste une minute le temps d'embrasser
maman oui elle importait de malades mais
lyon regarde comme les jolies mouy un
joli 8 - joe lewis et l'empêchent j'ai
besoin de sentir la mercedes et que
jamais partagé par je suis partie ohlala
on va comme ralentissent et plutôt deux
fois c'est aller à ce soir ils épient
tâche est de meilleure humeur parce que
j'ai besoin d'avoir une conversation
sérieuse avec toi arabes ont aussi jugé
dans ce court
quel mois de la cour y voit qu'ils
voulaient les mongols il va pleuvoir
oui bah et ne plus jamais trop
oubliez moi ton père lui n'oublie jamais
et bien qu'il pleuve qu'il pleuve vivant
le déluge mais naturellement moi je suis
sorti sans parapluie
alors tant emprunta emballant ballon
quoi ça lui allait lancer mon sens
brest-rennes français voyant c'est une
pièce unique de musée et celui là ça ira
il n'est pas destiné aux lourds soient
naturels grand un béléné main en ogive
oui
tu sais qui tu vas bien ce parapluie
mais il te vante un chant très bon alors
qu'est ce qu'elle en parle me demandait
c'est au sujet d' arnaud y avait
longtemps c'est aux jambes
c'est surtout un impôt on fond tu
préfères samba sow choisi lundi delta
donné deux buts qu'ils en forme me fous
moi la fetwa dont je t'ai vu jouer à
quatre pattes quand tu es tout seul avec
lui faire tuer oui bon alors mais goutte
alors ça vient ça vient
franchement les prendra ta place
bon alors il a alors pas encore il
s'enlise pas bon il a quelque chose à me
demander lui aussi bon non je crois
qu'il a une bonne nouvelle à t'annoncer
robin je me méfie des bonnes nouvelles
ce sont les filles tu sais tu finirais
par hoflandt et la déprime histoire
vas-y vas-y lâche le paquet aujourd'hui
c'est mon jour mais tout le jour ce ton
jour
oui j'exagère et respecter le primat
l'espagne paraît maintenant les machines
en coupant la crème un fil de verre
dégage d'une poussière qui pique les
yeux alors les lunettes de protection ça
ne suffit plus on me réclame des
visières ans micka pourquoi pas des
tenue de scaphandrier pour tailler dans
les rayonnages demande un peu là non la
vérité c'est qu'ils savent pas quoi
inventer pour emmerder le patron
moi je te lis un suzanne ce pays est
foutu
bon alors qu'est ce que c'est que cette
bonne nouvelle a fait de même annoncé le
rincer quoi c'est encore un secret mais
je crois qu'il va se marier
bonjour déjà là je me sens à l'aise nous
entraîner c'est comme une bouffée de
printemps ces chaleurs je ne me déplace
jamais sans mon atomiseur de poche en
chiffres ça rafraîchit ce pas oui oui
bon ben ça alors les photos ça va de ma
porte je vous ai fait un peu attendre
monsieur l'appareil ne fonctionnait plus
rire à bord alors ben maintenant quelque
chose avec du ce qu'on a c'est pas il
s'est remis en marche dieu merci
enfin on ne donne pas un coup on appuie
chez le bouton c'est pas étonnant si
tout se déglingue scénique dans cette
usine
bien sûr monsieur plus jeune vous avez
raison comme d'habitude monsieur puis
j'en ai fait pas attention mademoiselle
nadège mon mari se surmène il ne dort
pas assez il est encore en train 4
heures du matin pensez un acheteur
allemand qu'il a fallu trier dans les
bois
non c'est le hezbollah s'attend je
cherche un peu de café ça doit changer
ça et moi ça qu'est ce que c'est que
cette histoire d'acheteurs je vais vous
expliquer non non non inutile je ne dors
pas tout bonnement écoutez je vous
assure dans l'écouté mais non non en
tout cas pour demain soir ceinture vous
n'aurez qu'à retourner voir vos [ __ ] je
crois qu'il est encore assez chaud j'ai
moi aussi comme un goût amer dans la
bouche en effet mal à plusieurs votre
mari se surmène de prix et mieux le
surveiller
qu'est ce qu'elle a et laisse tomber
oh mais tu l'as brusco robert tu devrais
être plus gentils avec elle
lt si dévoués en insensible mais selon
moi la balle au bond alors quoi alors
leur angoisse marié il est amoureux
voiture c'est pas merveilleux très peu
pour moi entretenir un nouveau village
de ton fils de te demande de rien oui
non mais s'ils se marient alors là ça va
venir
mais laurent gagne ça fait juste plus
qu'elle est la fille qui doit mettre
gracieusement la laitue pense pas folle
elle a du fond cnrs et qui a des parents
derrière quand bien même il faudra les
aider un petit coup au début
à quoi ça sert gagner autant d'argent au
pis si tu ne veux pas je le fasse sur
sur mes revenus personnels tu sais que
trop moche on la fin griboval abu écoute
on verra on verra
quant aux 4 je te rassure tout de suite
au sujet de cette jeune fille ses
parents sont souvent très à l'aise c'est
la fille marc ysaye de la pâtisserie
marc ysaye de la place de la cathédrale
leur fille unique l'héritière floriane
marc ysaye aulas nom de dieu il paraît
qu'elle est charles andes
elle étudie le piano j'aurais préféré
qu'elle joue du trombone à coulisse
teneurs non non non je ne veux pas que
ce mariage mais tu es anti drogue tu ne
connais même pas cette petite attend au
moins de l'avoir donc je la verrai
sûrement pas et leur rendez-vous sympa
la fine art qui sait apprécier tout
travaillé et pourquoi pas ce qu'ils
tiennent boutique dans un trafic et
baronne saint fraigne en écoute alors ne
discute pas parce que le néo pro sapât
qu'est ce que tu as mis en avant tu
m'épouser les filles du psg
pourquoi ça ne te plaît pas ça mais pas
à pelé pas idiot mais peut-on savoir
pourquoi et ben mettons que j'aime pas
les gâteaux alors ça c'est nouveau chez
nous parce que leur banque de la sécu
temps serait rendue malade enfin fou -
la paix civile
donc tu sais c'est pas ton consentement
que je les félicite et je lui simplement
de faire part d'un projet pour lequel je
souhaitais son approbation
tu as toujours tout fait pour contrarier
quand je pense que la petite lou ne
téléphonait tous le top ont joué en
déduit merci bien ce poids tabac et
squats à bat yam et les hauts fourneaux
a dit si l'avion décroche deux hauts
fourneaux et a pas voulu que tu es para
bellum un monsieur est un intellectuel
ou un serveur d'être démodé m'a pas aidé
les choses ont changé depuis sa jeunesse
nous on se marie plus pour la dot
il dansait pour moi depuis dix ans
baptiste alors tu insultes de ta mère
d'un arm épargnez-nous déconnante papa
je suis venue pour l'anniversaire de
maman oblige pas partir en claquant la
porte du moins pas avant demain bon
tiens came to see semble-t-il survolté
nous parlerons tout ça plus tard yann
presse j'espère que tu te montrera plus
conciliant si non alors je te lis tout
de suite
il n'en est pas question alors tu
oublies la petite marquise et baby when
she rien sur tout actif à tout se
passera quand même très bien ce soir je
te le prouver et ambulatoires batwa
naturel est prêt à leur donner sa
bénédiction évident non quand on est le
fils pujol des usines michonneau plus
jeune épouse est une fille marc ysaye
disons le mot disons le sait c'est une
mésaventure ridicule robert nous ne
sommes pas sortis non plus de la cuisse
de jupiter fruits et ben moi j'ai
toujours cherché à m'élever en tout cas
d' forme et ont fait ces différents
essais de le comprendre
moi si tu veux que je te donne mon avis
ton avis oui qu'elle allait
dans la vie bat robin non je ne te
dérange que de partager le mien le reste
c'est du temps et des paroles perdues
axel
là alors là la raison joël je suis
vraiment une potiche ouais une potiche
ah oui je suis là posé dans un coin j'ai
pas vraie pensée ni de m'exprimer je
faisais partie du décor fut rien ah bon
alors toi aussi c'est la contestation
dia
et pas satisfaite de danseurs mais si
des scripts du 10 mai sylvain sim est
étincelant mais non mais non non non
mais quoi non mais tu manques de 400 je
vais dire pense qu'ils allaient trop
ménager le sud une petite prime dans mes
sites - à des femmes aussi gâtés que toi
après 30 ans de mariage à bombay a bon
tu vois tes combles étaient bien
obligées de l'aneth
cette fois il s'agit du bonhomme monfils
et au risque de te sur trop de repères
je te préviens je ne cèderai pas de
menton noble et réalisme j'ai souvent eu
lieu alors écoute alors puisque tu m'y
oblige alors je vais très bien et
quelque chose alors quelque chose qui va
pas tête articulièrement agréable en
tant qu après tout tu leur as voulu
alors voilà j'ai de bonnes raisons de
croire que floriane marc ysaye est un
petit peu ma fille ait commencé un petit
peu on n'est jamais tout à fait sûr de
ces choses là mais sa mère mail avait
affirmé en tout cas et comme la pauvre
n'est plus de ce monde attends attends
attends parce que ça me dois je
comprendre que mal à martizay était la
maîtresse
il faut croire
c'est pas pour dire mais tu aura
vraiment été marié lizin contient oui
bataille
enfin là il est un peu tard d'ailleurs
me dit sport tu t'en n'était jamais
douté parce que j'aurai du mois il est
vrai que nous étions obligés d'être
particulièrement discret elle était
mariée
[Musique]
il fallait pas aimer les soupçons du
mari et voilà
avec moi ça avec moi l'important sahbi
ben tiens prenez moins très confiant
quand tu prends avec des noms
mais quel jour où c'est bien simple tout
daikin ouvrière et est assez joli ça ne
freinait pas et sous mon propre toit
cette petite femme de ménage anges et la
guadeloupéenne que tu réinstaller dans
l'ue à lyon moi j'ai fermé les yeux sur
tout j'ai tout encaisser jma lisais le
journal 17 août à regina et aujourd'hui
tu m'annonce que tu as faim enfin à
marquise et alors là bas aujourd'hui
yanam 5,9 pour moi c'est la même chose
oui j'adorerais tout ça c'est la faute
de ton fils de murray ils avaient bien
mérité la petite partie des salons
croteau a battu mais attendez pas battu
temps serait pas plus mal tomber parce
que je l'avais bien oublié à cet esprit
brillant enfin près celle d'un coach l'a
rappelé mon vivant
on n'avait pas eu le temps d'acheter un
cadeau n'est de vertières tu nous fais
un boulot avec un faveur bien
ah non mais coûte afin soit pas méchante
suzanne toujours me dégoûte sommes fort
tu veux que je te demande pardon
j'aimerais ça veut dire oui c'est pas
tant oui enfin quoiqu'il en soit bien
dans ses produits sur le mariage entre
l'iran et la petite marquise est bon
quel est son présent déjà c'est pas vrai
il connaît même pas le nom de sa fille
enfin tu qu'on met racks et il envisage
alors ils doivent déjà couché ensemble
tu te rends compte des risques la
consanguinité à eva joly lhbbf et tu
pousses rimbaud tout au noir toi oui et
je ne parle pas des antécédents alcolea
bon avant parce qu'on buvait chez les
plus jeunes ça aussi comme la vie cajun
anale non non non non non cédées
michonneau dont je parle
didon le pp la part d'un an le faut
parce qu'il mettait une goutte de café
dans sanyo
quelques petites et gérer à la fois
revenir à ton fils à me faire le plaisir
de tout mettre en oeuvre pour le
détourner de sa déplorable projet on va
d'ailleurs que je suis même pas du
meilleur voyage en mésopotamie enfin la
halle devrait faire ces fouilles
archéologiques ça le changera les idées
mal et bien alors s'ils s'entêtent on
sera bien obligé du trajet morceaux
joués par m'embarrasser mois avec des
emmerdes avant de se révéler de quoi au
nom de dieu
oui l'état belge arrive
qu'est-ce qu'ils allaient la série
continue ils ont débrayé à l'atelier 4
voilà qu'on les sent pas les infos temps
pas mal des millions de 50 ans le côté
mais qu'est ce que tu veux faire la peau
de poissy l'approché besoin de personne
pour les remettre en marche les machines
installées ce n'est pas dans ta femme
n'est pas une machine que tu remettra en
marche aussi facile on va filmer s'est
passé et le coût de la petite marquise
est une autre apport dans la vie est
encore là cette fois ci tu as été un
petit peu trop un témoin mais pourquoi
avant dieu cette malheureuse passade
remonte à si loin mais c'est la goutte
d'or est bon là couteau la goutte d'eau
qui fait déborder la potiche
je vous dis pas le contraire monsieur le
préfet mais ils ont plutôt l'air de
durcir leur position
oui je sais bien qu'il faut éviter
l'intervention des forces de l'ordre
ça fait tout de même plus de 24 heures
que mon père est séquestrée dans son
bureau
donc nous pouvons pas communiquer avec
lui ils ont débranché le téléphone mali
paraît super des jo est loué oui bien
sûr j'ai alerté son avocat m e p2 sharp
les des amis alors le temps qu'il arrive
assez rarement été là à quoi un
médiateur qu'elle médiateur et puis je
connais mon père il refusera de négocier
sous la contrainte
oui oui c'est sans doute la sagesse mais
cet immobilisme est plutôt éprouvant
surtout pour papa je reste en contact
avec oui mais mes respects monsieur le
préfet alors qu'est ce que me dit qu'il
faut laisser mûrir la situation du paris
ne pas se mouiller et ben tu voudrais
quoi qu'il envoie les crs avec des
matraques et des gaz lacrymogènes
woods s'ils ne veulent pas comprendre
trois ans rien ne se résout jamais par
la violence avait cette année il faut le
dire c'est qu'ils ont commencé mais non
non non si papa n'avait pas fait
irruption comme un fou dans l'atelier 4
et cogner sur ce contremaître toute l'ue
il ne se serait pas mis en grève par
solidarité nous n'en serions pas là la
raison pendant qu'ils regrettent le
manque de diplomatie de papa voilà tout
naturellement toi tu es basculement
débauche à côté de toi manassen manette
mission accomplie bon alors racontez
vous l'avez l'instant si vous voulez
bien que je reprenne souffle
non non je n'ai pas fumé depuis des
grèves a accepté de lui faire passer le
panier de provisions avant tu vois on
bien sûr ils n'avaient rien mangé depuis
hier ils ont toutes examinées on aurait
cru que j'avais dissimuler une lime dans
le camembert et d'ampoulés froid une
corde à deux ils ont même goûté le
beaujolais les bandages
vous avez essayé de lui parler derrière
la pomme non non il n'y avait pas moyen
mais j'ai quand même crié courage patron
nous sommes avec vous oui bah vous avez
des problèmes des gens tous conspué mais
ça m'est égal
son dévouement aux patrons ne m'attire
pas la sympathie du personnel ça je vous
prie de croire et quand je me suis
retrouvé tout seul essayant de me frayer
un passage pour arriver jusqu'ici ça je
vous avoue que je n'en menais pas large
tous ces visages hostile qui
m'entouraient il ya là une brute cas
aussi porté la main sur moi ou on vous a
giflé pas mais non mais là ils m'ont
attaqué dans le dos
enfin un peu plus bas comment un bon
mais ça ça peut passer pour un hommage
faut pas tout prendre mal chez moi à ma
place
ça c'est pas toi que rapporté que ça
génère du mal à me serais tu peux être à
faire je sais très bien que je suis tout
de suite allé qu'est ce que je pourrais
faire seul contre tous
alors alors rien je craque je vais
craquer ayong ratings tu as pu proposer
un fou j'ai somnolé humeur s'était passé
est une cédera jamais coup après cette
nuit d'emplois ça mon anniversaire je me
souviens qu est ce que tu as et les ai
laissés chez marie luce elle veut les
gardes avec les siens autant qu'ils
soient éloignés de cette atmosphère
d'agitation et de l on est si facilement
traumatisé à cette action vous dire
combien je suis
m
non
donc non manque
l'usiné ne pas occuper ça il doit se
retourner dans sa tombe lui qui était si
aimé de ses ouvriers
quand je pense qu'il est passé au
travers de 36 cents un cent jours
d'arrêt de travail
je me souviens chaque ouvrier qu'il
prenait sa retraite il offrait
personnellement une montrant sa photo
dédicacée et une paire de charentaises
et voilà que le drapeau rouge flotte sur
nos bâtiments basse et fraîche mois
qu'il faudra un peu plus qu'une paire de
charentaises si on veut que tout rentre
dans l'ordre
tu atteindrions aux délégués syndicaux
oui mais ma démarche n'était qu'à titre
familial et humanitaires au niveau de
l'entreprise je ne représente rien
personne ne m'a délégué pouvoir pour
négocier mais moi je manque réagir mais
que faire de plus aimerait bien du tfc
est mentionné pour écouter alors
essayons de faire le point mais qu'est
ce qu'il réclame au jus l'atelier 4 à
débrayer
parce qu'ils exigent de nouveaux
sanitaires oui ça ne me paraît pas une
revanche révocation abusive il date de
la construction de l'usiné mais
maintenant maman mais tu comprends rien
tout ça n'est qu'un prétexte politique
ils veulent tous maintenant ça le
refrain habituel
les 13e voir augmentation des effectifs
suppression d'une surveillance
tatillonne tu prétexte de réduire
absente et on se tait salaires réduction
des heures de travail
évidemment évidemment ça fait beaucoup à
la fois c'est immonde babin c'est lui
qui sème le vent de la révolte
il légalise le entendu à la radio hier
il me donne la chair de poule moins
stable a dit m pelli chat mais comment
tu tic soit pas encore là celui là va
arriver il va arriver on va c'est vrai
ça rame ya c'est tout de même pas les
kamchatka mais il rate toujours sa
correspondance ça c'est bien connu on
sent là les heures passent et mon pauvre
papa est toujours prisonnier de ses
bottes finish orageux
où s'arrêtera t sas en vue clarté ça
c'est chaud chaud chaud chaud chaud
dan et moi réalisons les mouches la démo
débauche il est allé dans la mienne à
l'eau aux métaux
sa faute est irrespirable dans le bureau
du patron dessous cette verrière et
l'air conditionné qui est en panne à les
tortionnaires
mon dieu pourvu qu'ils pensent à prendre
ces gouttes elle oublie toujours le
savez bien si je n'étais pas là ça veut
dire si vous n'étiez pas là madame pujol
rêver enfin si nous n'étions pas là ne
vous excusez pas cette crise va se
dénouer d'une façon ou d'une autre un il
veut bien finir par nous londres dans
quel état
maki
en tout mal chaussés pas de suggérer moi
je ne suis qu'une femme adore john
o'shea comme celui-là or s'il accepte de
faire l'échangé qui me garde ce gentil
première fleur gamme maman car elle
aussi elle attend des nouvelles de
maurienne floriane sont rafraîchies et
floriane la future belle soeur manon
sembla alors ça ça notre problème
chaque chose en son temps si je ne
reviens pas la morale aux non je veux
dire si je ne suis pas de retour trois
quarts de riner dia floriane que je ne
rentrerai pas avec elle à paris ce soir
qu'elle ne m'attends pas leurs
engagements avec un malabar assaillants
n'ouvrent la vie pourvu qu'ils se
montrent compréhensifs tout cas ils sont
de plus en plus nombreux dans la cour en
huit mois 10 des banderoles ils ont même
pas des jaunes et une description au
goudron sur le mur et jean légal hitler
est clair alors les cette chercheuse par
la petite mèche sur le front et encore
attention à chaque opéra pop et comme
chiennes de garde
elle se roule au pied du premier but
tout est indoor ils sont partout en tout
cas la maison à témoin marie antoinette
c'est dans la même situation il rit elle
n'a jamais perdu sur ces contrôles nous
appelons ça ne sais pas si bien terminée
landry
si ce moment là on est entraîneur et
soir
l'espagne veut émerger un si grand
rythme de samba vous fait rire vente ou
pas oui je
bien jeter d'autant plus que certaines
revendications ne sont pas totalement
injustifiée ainsi la cinquième semaine
de congés voilà elle retourne ça reste
tu voyais que je ne retourne rien du
tout il faut se mettre de temps en temps
la place des salariés c'est pas et ça
vous savez pas ce que c'est que de
projeter tous les matins à 8h évidemment
vous voulez rouler toute l'année vous la
fille du patron ainsi dans sa banlieue
de l'esa cours alors nous avons toutes
les raisons précitées ne faut pas si
vous feront vous attendez quelques uns
j'attends quelqu'un oui à les ouvrir
pour m'échapper mais bon c'est maman qui
est top secret
on n'était pas possible vous savez qui
est la wii fait entrer
cet homme ici
vous remercie monsieur le député maire
d'avoir répondu si vite à mon appel mais
comment sétois m'avancer - maman keith
santé à 0 quand le patron saura ça
je vous en prie monsieur le député maire
asseyez-vous là à la droite
eh bien on vient voir madame me voilà
quelque chose je ne suis pas ici pour
faire des mondanités
je suppose que vous comprenez combien ma
présence dans votre maison peut être un
solide
si vous croyez que ça a été facile de
décrocher mon téléphone pour solliciter
cette entrevue
alors qu'attendez-vous du consul et
piqué mais je vous demande d'user de
toute votre influence pour faire libérer
mon mari mais qu'est ce que j'ai à voir
là dedans c'est avec les délégués
syndicaux qui faute aux médias le renier
mon mari ne refusera d'en laisser
montant actuel bah alors appelé les
forces de l'ordre dans l'intérêt général
je crois qu'il vaudrait mieux que les
choses s'arrangent à l'amiable à
l'amiable
quand il ya eu la tête à la personne
humaine 4 l'ouvrier a été molesté mais
mon mari est un impulsif du tout tout de
suite que son poids est parti tout seul
ce sont des choses qui arrivent même à
vous on peut vous rambert en sait
quelque chose lui est fendue l'arcade
sourcilière elle points de suture est
encore visible vingt-cinq ans après et
bien se souvenir aurait dû lui donner à
réfléchir faut pas vous montrer si si
agressif
voulez-vous que je vous dise ce que vous
représentez un monsieur dans citi dit il
je sais une affreuse bons joueurs mais
bien pire que cela
vous êtes vous êtes un sens eu peur j'ai
du sang des travailleurs
la citadelle de l'égoïsme ccleaner des
lentilles le dernier bastion de ska
régime féodal
oui c'est tout ouïe depuis toujours je
mène un combat quand on se vautre
espèces quel est votre raison d'être la
société bvt l'inutile poupée le luxe la
complice consentante d'un cynique
exploiteurs du peuple bull à la mémère
en diamanté
cave être carrière une fois gras et
marchal sur ces bisons oui et je vais
vous dire je ne suis pas
particulièrement ces sept ouvriers non
sais pas mais je trouve ça un peu fort
quand même pas fait pour me résumer vous
m'inspirez que mépris et répulsion
vraiment oui madame freinant dit dont
monsieur le député maire
vous n'avez pas toujours dit ça
bon vous ne voyez pas que je fais
allusion pas du tout et bien cherché
bien cherché bien je ne regarde jamais
derrière moi seul l'avenir m'intéresse
et bien moi je vais vous rafraîchir la
mémoire parce que nous allons tous faire
semblant d'avoir oublié tous les deux je
ne vous ai pas toujours été aussi
antipathique roulait bien près temps où
on ne revenons pas trop le passé ni vous
ni moi n'avons et gagner pourquoi notre
moment d'égarement serait-il
incompatibles avec l'image du tribun de
gauche
vous êtes devenu en tout cas avec
l'image est une épouse et une mère que
tout le monde croit irréprochable sans
vous on ne sait pas me culpabiliser hier
après tout nul n'est à l'abri d'une
erreur de jeunesse
je le dis pas pour vous comme pour moi
quant à fait tous deux séparés
vous étiez filles et femmes de patrons
et moi pour les ter avec vous j'ai trahi
vie mon mari quel est le pire c'est un
peu tard sans se poser de questions
enfin si ça devait peser si lourd sur
votre conscience
il fallait réfléchir allemand et une
femme séduit parce que c'est moi qui
vous ai fait suite à la mauvaise foi de
ces riches d'asie notamment été dérobées
sous les fenêtres de ma salle de bains
mais j'étais là que je pars qui manque à
lyon mais qui s'est trouvé comme par
hasard sous la route de caudry yeux le
jour où j'ai un peu de poids mais
c'était mon itinéraire avec maintien
j'ai toujours assister mon prochain même
si je ne partage pas ses opinions
politiques
il fallait vous voir dans votre petit
tauromachie toute tâche et de cambouis
le cri calamel je revenais d'un mariage
doivent être ridicule avec ma caprine et
mais au talent avait souri abandonna
pour l'instant toute l'arrogance de
votre casque faisant grand père était
chaudronnier moi je vous échangez vos
pneus vous avez refusé fièrement le
pourboire que je voulais vous donner
oui mais j'ai accepté de cigarettes et
nous sommes vous avez fumé ensemble à
l'ombre de noisetiers au bord de la
route avant peu de nous enfoncer dans le
sous bois
vous avez pensé que j'étais une femme
facile je ne protestez par les hommes se
font une piètre idée nous dans ces cas
là pourtant j'avais déjà fait des
excuses
l'énervement de champagne maritime
négligé et pourquoi le nier vous étiez
boga dans votre tricot de corps et votre
réputation de grande beuverie prestige
bref j'essaie condé ah bon ou comment
avant autant de témoins autant de
versions vous événement m'a dit dans ces
moitiés vous aurez vente et peut-être
parce en passant passant alors quoi
qu'il en soit de même reprenez vos
distances et vous tiriez définitivement
les rideaux de votre salle de bain boeuf
j'étais une femme mariée j'étais maman
j'avais mais combien de fois ai-je
trambly qu'on doit les augmenter de vos
ex est en train de voter mais pour que
le premier mot je suis peut-être la
langue du peuple mais je sais me taire
car l'honneur d'une dame est en jeu
n'empêche que comme autres ss de marie
ma fac est dehors j'ai été à deux doigts
de le traiter de cocu haut
salut pas été très bon goût talent il
vous aurait pas cru
c'est quand même curieux que après tant
d'années vous évoquez l'incidence du
clan crevé je pensais que vous l'avez
oubliée alors pourquoi méfiez-vous du
regard que nos fonctions respectives
lors maintenant présent 100 ans
parce que dans ces circonstances je me
suis de madame plusieurs la femme de
votre ennemi tout demeure un petit
sourire lahoucine de kollywood ancien
député-maire la page est tournée depuis
longtemps mais je vais vous faire un
aveu rien que d'évoquer ce souvenir
je respire encore l'odeur des jacinthes
sauvage faut-il que vous y ait besoin de
mes services
enfin ce que je viens de vous dire je le
pense sincèrement
vous voulez comprendre votre mari vous
acceptez n'est déjà pas dit ça
d'ailleurs je vous répète
la décision dépend du seul comité
d'entreprise mais mon mari il acceptera
une commission de conciliation
qu'est ce qu'ils me prouvent mejia du
tout ça j'essaierai de persuader
pourtant vous auriez votre beau dire que
c'est l usine de papes attend pas en
plein milieu
je détiens départ nos affaires combien
doit vous participez au conseil
d'administration n'ont jamais rien du
tout robert à la procuration
enfin je peux vous dire une chose c'est
ne s'agissait que de moi il ya longtemps
qu'on préfère les sanitaires
non mais il s'agit là que détails
mineurs dans la liste de revendications
des problèmes moi je joue au plus pressé
si j'accepte de parler aux délégués cet
amas vous acceptez j'ai pas dis ça je
dis si j'obtiens à libération cette
ordure le plus jeune était pas dans le
vocabulaire politique pas fait si
j'obtenais la libération de votre mari
vous vous doutez bien qu'il me faudrait
une contrepartie une autre partie et
dames
comment comptez vous me payez de retour
monsieur le député maire
là je n'ose comprendre à nos sages
wen
salif sané plus abaca muller de soweto
basaula gentil plus sain tout la
romanesque jeunes femmes en robes
d'organdi comme moi je pique pas un
instant je suis confuse au congé au mais
il faut pas d'ailleurs vous savez un bon
paquet postal américain
par le centre du sujet là non quand je
vous demande de contrepartie je pense
son rôle éventuel que vous pourriez
jouer dans une nouvelle orientation de
lucide et ça veut dire quoi ça ça veut
dire que si des réformes radicales ne
sont pas s'appliquer dans l'avenir
immédiat
vous irez de grève en grève sera
fermeture de l'autre qu'on prétend 300
ouvriers au chômage c'est ce que je vous
ai vite et non parce que je peux faire
mon mari mes coups de gueule elle a
dorénavant je peux tu auras faudra bien
que c'est bon je fais ce qu'on me
demande est bon à prendre quand même
plus quand même bon je vais essayer de
convaincre les non merci alors pas de
merci c'est donnant donnant la seule
raison pour moi de venir chez vous
c'était de défendre l'intérêt des
travailleurs
là c'est vraiment qu'est ce que vous
imaginiez c'était un peu pour moi
c'était aussi un peu pour vous
mon frère khaled emmanuel sens au niveau
électeurs mais tu n'y es pas du tout
c'est pas eux
c'est papa
mon permis de voir j'ai essayé de
raisonner de lui dire qu'il fallait
qu'ils acceptent de faire certaines
concessions
finalement la prix m'a sauté dessus en
me traitant de tous les noms
heureusement que le piquet de grève
était là pour le ceinturer tient tête à
ces conditions il serait peut-être
prudent de laisser mijoter 1 contre l'as
marsa morts sur la conscience
je vous en conjure monsieur le
député-maire visées de toute votre four
pour le tirer de la vie 8
alors je vais te plairait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va lui faire un tel un plaisir de
vous revoir aux patrons
ces camps mais le diable il la tient sa
vengeance mais tu te rends compte que tu
nous a livré à 8 y était pour rien je
vous assure il n'est pas si mes chances
[Applaudissements]
mon dieu mon dieu
j'ai bien peu de céleri dans le bouillon
ce soit moins crade docteur est parti
laurent est en train de raccompagner
jusqu'à sa voiture
et qu'est ce qu'il a dit long sur un
avantage tout à l'heure mais il n'a pas
caché à robert frenette à cardiaque
n'étaient pas les plus brillants quand
j'ai vu traverser la cour de l'usiné
tout à l'heure pour venir jusqu'ici
j'ai été tout retourné quoi se se fier
pdg ce chef d'entreprise aux pantalons
toujours impeccable ce boss dont on
discutait pas les ordres et devant quito
puis enfin il est élevé oui mais il
n'était pas rasé il n'était pas rasé
lunettes a changé depuis
depuis deux jours il n'était pas au
mieux de sa forme son beam pavin qui
marchaient devant lui l'air triomphant
reste tout de même grâce à lui si
rebelle a été libéré à l'humiliation at
il dû attendre ce moment où il ferait
manger la poussière à son ancien patron
bhl ne recensait pas tous a menti alors
il ya de quoi vous briser un homme même
sans regarder plus même je vous assure
il a du ressort
si nous en son nom bien soigné par un
oui tu es allé
on y va
certes il a des défauts qu'on défend
mais il a ses bons côtés aussi n'est ce
pas seulement faut bien connaître comme
vous c'est moi pour les apprécier
dallas s'est passé est aussi malade que
le fait quand le médecin mais les plus
infernal fait jamais y'a pas moyen de
tenir au lit comment mais le docteur a
bien commandé une infirmière qu'il lui
faut c'est une catcheuse
on ne me dit pas plus élevé ici la même
décidé de prendre une douche moi j'ai
pas pu l'empêcher lignes bougent tout
seul dans son état c'est dangereux
chinoise el nahdha j'ai vraiment une
secrétaire modèle tu ne trouves femme
n'est ce pas c'est elle même qui a
préparé son bouillon de légumes non mais
et c'est elle qui le mal en ce moment là
figurent trois mois le docteur était
formel faut qu'ils arrêtent toute
activité pendant trois mois non et c'est
tout de même pas si grave que ça
pourrait le devenir papa est à la merci
d'un oedème pulmonaire
avant toute chose il devra passer une
semaine à l'hôpital pour des examens
approfondis savait comment devient on
sait ça contre belle usine à user
lui-même marchasson lui dire les
catastrophes s'agite aux catastrophes
si arnaud était là sont pas une de plus
si tu savais ce qu'il pense de toi alors
de chipoter pas tout le temps à mes
enfants et ça suffit donc toi tu rentres
à paris ce soir n'y pense pas je veux
pas te laisser débattre seul au milieu
de tous ces emmerdements tu es gentil
mais ton travail je m'arrangerais seul
organe n'a pas téléphoné mais non je
l'appellerai tout à l'heure elle doit se
demander ce qui se basait dhabhawi à
floriane
il commence par être un peu débordé mais
enfin délégués syndicaux est juste une
réponse immédiate oui considère qu'à
libera pujol j'appelle premier pas les
négociations seraient très différents
anémone mémoire et les pannes n'est pas
en étant en ce moment comme de médecins
sur dix y organisera un sédatif
peut-être demain après une bonne nuit de
sommeil sera-t-il en mesure de recevoir
quelques visites ma gueule mais c'est la
mérite
m'enfin c'est la méritais pas dis lui
toi c'est vrai mon père a besoin de
repos il est très affaibli fica médical
peut-être pas question ne pas spolier le
meeting j'ai engagé une responsabilité
et si j'ai plaidé la cause du patron
c'est pour mieux défendre celle des
travailleurs ne l'oublié pas enfin ils
ont besoin de dormir aussi c'est vrai ça
depuis deux jours qu'il ne fait plaisir
franchement une bonne nuit entre des
draps de vias frein avec leur petite
femme ou que ce serait sympathique et
donato notre meilleure humeur royaume
eh bien on voit bien madame que c'est
paris des classes laborieuses par
quelques mètres vous avez de les
remettre très éloignées le fait de me
taire
bon enfin les travailleurs sont prêts à
passer bien des nuits blanches pour que
leurs revendications soient satisfaites
ils se battent pour l'idéal il
soutiendrait sans lui et ça on saura ce
graphique comme jerry moyes cet article
est tous un peu toi
attention non il faudrait pas essayé de
jouer au plus malin avec nous vous
savons capables de porter des coups bas
nous sommes sur nos gardes et ceci est l
avertissement solennel à défaut de
négociations rapidement tata mais je
vous le prédis il aura tout faux les
ateliers vous en ferez en terrain
conquis dans l'allée l'on vous vous
aimez tapis persans revo semelle tout
crotté techno et le sédatif ses mots et
non pas comme un sultan me suis jamais
fait dans la concertation impôts si la
gueule petit quant au docteur a dit de
faire et qu'on lui aussi est en rouge
est tous des cons ils préfèrent
d'ailleurs c'est très simple je suis
cernée par les ponts
mais tu n'es pas mal embouché taisez
vous et gap n'est pas dans son état
normal
j'ai toujours connu comme ça
brutal des spots injurieux ça c'est vous
qui le cherchait un petit militer
messieurs et faire la peau du cou
j'avais jeté dehors par la peau du cou
ce roquet other de moscow mois soit
raisonnable bien chez votre coeur
monsieur plus chaud alors qu'est ce que
votre amie est tous derrière mon dos
mais tu crois quand à libérer comme ça
mais non il a fallu jeter du lest à
jeter du lait calme toi j'ai simplement
première monsieur le député-maire contre
sa libération que tu rêverais
attentivement et objectivement les
revendications des travailleurs et pour
être tout à fait franche avec toi je te
lis tout comme gens la trouvent
certainement
et bien moi aussi quand on pense qu'en
1983 vous êtes le seul à avoir la clé de
votre w c est que je suis obligé chaque
fois le descendre à l'étagé pouvoir même
mademoiselle note
oui alors vous perdez rien pour attendre
à toutes les deux heures là mon action
seize de but et nous sommes dans
l'impasse et il faut négocier
bon alors comme ça tu es pour le
certaines revendications du personnel
j'ai toujours pensé qu'ils avaient
tendance à exagérer vous et dans tous
les domaines tu vois ce que je vous dis
pour le lavage de cerveau ça fun bike
bon alors vous pourrez dire demain par
otellini syndicaux que s'ils veulent
toucher leur mois de congés payés il
fallait le reprend le travail de demain
puisque le juge des référés s'est
déclaré incompétent je vais demander au
tribunal la levée des piquets de grève
voilà alors parce que l'on croyait
lessivé filet écoute par son frère et
moi ça la famille était prête à brader
lusine voilà je vous montrais moi je
vais vous montrer ce que c'est qu'un
patron qui en a deux c'est plus
librement
je vais vous montrer fraîche et en
prendre un peu d'air ma famille et moi
quand même
comment vous sentez vous monsieur pujol
non cette fois ci alors là j'ai bien que
j'allais passer le répondeur le docteur
sera pas là avant 8h responsables ont
appelé police secours
pourquoi pas les pompiers alors tu fais
18 ça les fait et je me sens léger un
petit peu mieux
oui oasis et pas trop vite ah bah c'est
pas encore pour cette poussée tient pas
sur ses jambes mais ne parlent pas ne
s'agite pas tu vas au domaine des
grosses colères qui va faire plaisir
d'écouter docteur la case c'est un
comble enfin d'accord de maquis autres
philippe moitié company of me suffit jol
penser un peu à vous et à moorhead
accord bon et lisez les voyons les
choses en face vivant dans les
circonstances actuelles que du prennent
un peu de recul je me permets de vous
signaler que le comité d'entreprise est
décidé à examiner les comptes de près
quoi quoi est ce que vous jouez
je me suis laissée dian qui s'étonnait
un peu que votre mercedes 480 sur
considéré comme voiture de fonction que
votre appartement d'abord il ya votre
ménage domestique autres chasses gardées
la conte et leucan automobile arrive à
tous à papa ça passe sur les traits de
l'entreprise
qu est-ce que je t'avais dit et est ce
riva était un signe extérieur de minutes
mais non monsieur voulait se mettre une
casquette de capitaine tout ça pour
mieux draguer les minettes à ses troupes
elle peut même pas regarder un bateau
sans armement de mr mehdi la casquette
non mais non mais vraiment vous avez
tous décidé d'avoir ma peau il ya aussi
par était le mystérieux nouveau cahier
de commandes mais il est dans un
coffre-fort
ah bravo nadège alors là bravo tu
emploies je me méfierais est bon ça mais
on peut brouiller je vais penser à
l'augmentation parce que cette fois je
n'aimerais pas le petit doigt
moi ce que je vous ai dit si je
comprends bien monsieur le député maire
ont suggéré que mon père se fasse
remplacer provisoirement à la tête de
l'entreprise et un mollet ce que dit son
médecin
je vois même pas d'alternative on ne met
le couteau sous la gorge
bon alors écouté puisque vous êtes tous
contre moi alors que tu es d'accord qui
l'accusé y lit en fou alors de toute
façon n'est pas formé de pouvoir je les
dirai enfin que tes collaborateurs
alors là tous des incapables comme il
n'est pas question de mois non embalo
sûrement pour lui un bon pareil
alors quoi baki mais pourquoi pas vous
madame toujours en moi mais quoi
vous êtes la fille du fondateur la femme
du patron ça se justifierait je les
connais rien moi il s'agit pas de
diriger les usines apprend prendre part
il s'agit de s'asseoir dans le fauteuil
de papa et de laisser passer l'orage
ah bon c'est tout oui oui il n'est pas
question de te confier des
responsabilités là bas rien du tout moi
mais moi j'ai dit tout de même la petite
fille oui ben fait ce qu'on dit suzanne
migros toi quelqu'un ou d'ailleurs on
n'a pas le choix si c'est toi qui me le
demandent
évidemment je le prendrai aucune
décision sans en parler en bâtiment
richert vous acceptez la pudeur
si ces temps-là tianji allé deux fois
plus de temps jeu prévient un délégué
vous permettez que j'ai téléphoné alors
que fait-on pour avoir lui aussi nous
appuyer sur le bouton de gauche et vous
faites le 8 marie laure toile et dans
suzanne président directeur général
alors là c'est la meilleur ne rit pas
comme ça mais mourir de rire ce serait
plus gai
quand on attend mer noire je vais te
dire c'est plutôt qu'ils me les aurait
non c'est moi
ben oui c'était n'est pas dans son état
normal
entrée dans sa chambre au togo non pas
question du bouillon aux petits qu il
était gosse red bull et ça sort le
saceur il est proche même pas attendu
j'ai l'aï grévistes il faut n'est pas
moi même
bon alors on se la coulent douce aux
jouets belote pas de feignasses
qu'est ce que je dis là en moins
l'atmosphère bourgeoise cette maison est
contagieux bel effet la soupe c'est son
père n'en serions pas là toi se faire
avoir mais qui va dans le sens de
l'histoire partout les femmes prennent
le pouvoir du jeune homme
vous allez porter ce billet appris qu
est le porte parole du syndicat
voilà je lui demande de réunir le comité
en vue d'un premier contact avec le
nouvel interlocuteur proposé par la
direction ont échoué à long terme
il ya une réponse oui j'accepte tous ont
refusé ça alors ça
et c'est pas savoir 120 retrouver comme
ça sa forme dans la famille ne sont donc
pas ici sur la défensive avec vous plus
jamais vous méfier hong kong - oui c'est
pas parce qu'on n'est pas du même côté
de la barricade comme doit être à
couteaux tirés
on en est traité de sangsues mais
c'était symbolique
ah bon ah non alors comme ça savall et
tous les pas complètement pourri au mou
vous voulez dire des choses aimables
contenu
dans quel état d'esprit allez-vous
rencontrer le comité
moi je suis pour la conciliation à
condition bien sûr qu'ils n'ont pas trop
m'étaler vriendt des 22 trop ce que le
patron ne veut pas lui en donner assez
mais qu'est ce qu'ils réclament à part
les séries télé ça on va leur en faire
deux beaux tout neufs devraient pas
l'être alors revalorisation des salaires
oui réduction du temps de travail
le 13e mois et la cinquième semaine de
congés payés au prix rien que de très
légitime et la compétitivité dans tout
ça c'est qu'il va falloir en vendre des
parapluies et à quel prix pour faire
plaisir à tout ce petit monde jusqu'à
présent vous l'avez fait plaisir quand
vous même bon et le 13e mois
et puis quoi encore vrai d'abord qu'ils
figurent au calendrier celui là
on commence à parler de choses qui
n'existent pas mais c'est à parler de
choses qui n'existent pas tenter les
révolutions avant 1789 la liberté l'été
comme moi mais y'a pas moyen de discuter
avec vous allez voir avec quoi
si seulement moi j'étais un peu un peu
rondes et moi si j'étais à votre place
je préparais un petit topo un petit
twist ans avant vous allez nous ne
passerons pas fourni puisque je n'ai pas
l'habitude le topo alors je commencerai
par exemple par rené hambourg
mais les messages vous attendre alors
messieurs messieurs je viens vous dans
un esprit de compréhension
non faut pas dire ça pourquoi pourquoi
messieurs s'est froissé sexe et snob non
je vais leur dire mes amis je me dis que
c'est une jean port joli
il le savait très bien ils deviendront
peut-être ou alors là il faudrait des
actes pas trop la bad et veulent pas
rentrer je fasse un question
d'abord les bombes alors dans une
compression
je ne suis qu'une femme
d'accord mais pourquoi cette fois mais
ça vous serez contre les vaines paroles
d'ailleurs je n'ai pas à m'excuser une
femme la formule et que j'aurai tout ça
me minimise enfin vous ne comprenez pas
sur les prochains jeux
vous êtes complètement misogyne comment
osez-vous j'ai toujours ceux tenus avant
les revendications des femmes et ça
continue à se faire servir par sa petite
bonne femme je parie je ne suis pas
mariée est à marier quand on aime les
femmes ont les mariés vous savez ce que
vous vous êtes vous êtes un vieux
célibataire qui maîtrisent les femmes ou
la vie d'une personne
mais qu'est ce qui vous prend là je ne
dirais pas suffi de femmes
je dirais oui je suis questionnée pas la
roue peut dire est que si on commence à
partir sur de fausses données moi jouer
jouer cartes sur table avec eux et bien
mettre les choses au point
parce que monsieur le député maire ça me
plaise ou non
je suis une femme
mais ça me plaît ça plaît beaucoup vous
devriez vous en souvenir revenons à mon
discours
oui je suis une femme
virgule
s'il a prévenu le point d'interrogation
[Musique]
dans les solos pas dire oui que
l'avalanche a échoué une femme ne puisse
pas réussir à nos jeux pas bien pourquoi
ça c'est pas ça c'est pas gentil pour
robert byrd du couvre feu
une femme et la femme ne me suis plus
jeune c'est un peu comme s'il était mon
patron à mon style je peux t'on
facilement comprendre à 700 différence
que pour moi pas question de faire la
grève
et c'est pas mal ça
[Applaudissements]
vous savez quoi
quoi vous êtes mûr pour la tribune j'ai
néanmoins eu ouïe dire prête si vous
préférez me dire mais je préfère c'est
d'accord il faut attendre là comme ça
maintenant tout de suite aller si vous
voulez que le travail reprenne
rapidement les attendait comment pas
très avenant est plus dans l'effroi
poireauter aller au lit mais inutile
sera tout à fait ne peuvent bien
attendre encore deux minutes cela doit
les bonnes femmes
or y avait 20 ans n'est pas comme ça que
vous allez gagner nous a alors dit
abstenez vous de ce genre de remarque
monsieur le député maire
oui
[Applaudissements]
méthot peu nerveuse roi rama yade quoi
maman sortie de son petit train-train
dit alors à vous ça vous dirait l usine
pourquoi ça de vrai je sais pas vous
mais quand on a la chance est un fils à
papa
1 j'ai une tête de fils à papa c'est
quoi
vous êtes le fils plus jolie oui mais ça
m'intéresse pas tout ça
le fric la possession les avantages
d'ailleurs par principe je suis contre
l'exploitation de l'homme par l'homme
vous l'avez dit rentre terme ça avec lui
d'une fois et qu'est ce qu'il a dit il a
dit que c'est moi qui me ferait bouffer
par les autres alors voyez qu'épique
seiu cobra politique marc vous êtes à la
rue alors les manifs très peu pour moi a
pourtant à votre âge
c'est comme ça que s'expriment pas
toujours non la preuve
mais ça n'existe pas tenir à l'écart de
nos jours tout est à guidage monde
politique ne vous fatiguez pas avoir
mais qu'est ce qui vous intéresse alors
vous voulez le savoir la civilisation du
bassin de l'indus mayenne jodar haut et
à rapa troisième millénaire avant
jésus-christ et vous croyez qu'en ce
temps-là il ne faisait pas la politique
fait ce site surnom c'est intéressant de
parler avec vous et horaires
d'ailleurs moi j'aime bien changer les
idées avec des jeunes et je ne désespère
pas de vous convaincre de vos
responsabilités politiques
il faudra qu'on prend le pot 1 122
chevaux batterie vous voulez quant à la
papa très mauvais moral il rayon pas de
quoi se montrer optimiste je ne vois pas
comment on va pouvoir se débrouiller
tout seul ni en qui on pouvait avoir
confiance pour la conseiller bon alors
là je t'ai pas si c'est à moi pour une
solution madame mon rôle de médiateur va
s'arrêter là j'ai d'autres
préoccupations
quand on fabrique de parapluie à la main
devant les médias j'ai juste assez
d'intelligence pour voir clair dans
votre jeu 95 une marionnette entre
commun oui elle va mener cette
entreprise à la faillite
nous serons ruiné mes enfants n'auront
rien et bien ici que vous enfants
atteignant leur majorité le monde on a
pas mal changé
et plutôt que d'attendre l'usiné de
grand papa comme capitale il ferait bien
de compter sur leurs bras et celle en
matière grise
seulement voilà comment savoir si la
matière grise sera répartie avec égalité
ne sont pas encore là
hu
opération hostile qu'est ce que c'est
que le carnaval
enfin vous plaît pas ça mauritanie mais
c'est pas un peu trop leur café et
pourquoi tu étais même pas les origines
c'est plus un défi mais je ne suis pas
sûr qu'elle soit tout à fait approprié
mois ci c'est la rampe chez ces mots
fait bien pour la venue du ministre j'en
ai aujourd'hui l'occasion de remettre
ces trois provinces n'ont pas voulu
passer pas c'est dans la poule c est
pourquoi au contraire je veux honorer
les travailleurs
c'est pour ça que j'ai mis tous mes
bijoux mais après tout ce je ne les
aurais pas
il est normal qu'ils en profitent un peu
mais moi je n'y comprends rien aux
contingents qu'ils soient fiers de moi
souvenez-vous d'ebita est à vérone avec
toute cette quincaillerie quand vous
mangez dans ma chair député maire je me
sens conforme à l'image font droit parce
que c'est comme ça qu'ils soient
présentes une patronne alors je vais
être la patronne sage et du poids
croyez-moi plus on sent faible plus il
faut border bon alors je vais tenter
vous on y va on y va aux jeunes c'est
raté
est ce qu'elle se sacrifie tellement
qu'est ce que tu veux dire je ne sais
pas me fais l'effet de la doublure qui
jouerait enfin le rôle de la vedette
ouais ben l'important est de savoir
comment il va le jouer tu entends c'est
pour maman sur réception j'en ai peur ne
dramatisez pas les voilà qu'ils
rebroussent chemin mais je vois bien le
mal comme des boucles avec une tomates
bien mûres
l'opération prestige c'était pas une
très bonne idée
oui maman je crois qu'il vaudrait mieux
renoncer hier ce que tu ne connais pas
mon garçon qu'une devise jusqu'au bout
jusqu'au bout des tomates
toi tu ça me met en colère vous avez
bien peu d'autorité sont vos militants
on dirait je vous demande pardon madame
il s'agit d'éléments incontrôlés qui
sèment le désordre ça vous invite à fiac
donges les crs vont nettoyer tout ça
elle va papa
jamais la police tu franchiras écrits de
monuments à ba ouvrait cette fenêtre je
vais les haranguer la terrasse après tu
peux d'insister aimons leur vie énervé
est ce que je vous dis je vais t'en
avais vague pour si peu à chapeau la
vraie manquait pas de panache
c'est le sens michonneau il se réveille
on
[Applaudissements]
avant
quand tu là
camarades vous avez gagné
[Applaudissements]
oui
m
la direction est prête à négocier
[Applaudissements]
oui votre patron monsieur pujol
et contraint d'abandonner provisoirement
son poste pour raison de santé écrit
on se retrouvera les petits gars
ça peut fatiguer bon alors je vous
présente votre nouveau pdg
[Musique]
niggli d'accord aussi de sympathie me
vont droit au coeur
vous avez dit oui je voulais vous dire
que la direction est prête à faire un
effort
j'ai un programme je vais le soumettre à
un représentant
et si tout le monde y met un peu du sien
il n'y a pas de raison qu les choses ne
s'arrangent pas pas vrai toujours sale
et pas trop
[Applaudissements]
il s'est permis trier un moule écosse la
vieille c'est toi le pivot rien qui se
cache derrière un grand barbu le départ
coach n'a connu c'est déjà toi qui m'as
balancé la tomate approche un peu le
trac qu'elle vient ici bien je ne me
trompe pas c'est le jeune cricri dommage
monsieur christian pausé aussi vaillant
dispensaire quand je te fais d'habitude
à chaque séance il tombe de l'oeil
attention hein gare à tes fesses la
prochaine fois je n'ai pas coupé moi
tiens
en attendant en attendant une rose les
salaires ou là à une réduction du temps
de travail qui sont à l'étude
tout écouter tout de même ce que j'ai à
vous dire on va pas rester là sans rien
on va qu'est ce qu'on va faire
allez chiche on va repeindre tous les
ateliers chaque atelier dans la couleur
votée par le personnel
ça fait joli alors je vais vous mettre
des fleurs avec des géraniums tous les
balcons ou c'est champêtre 1
on va renouveler l'ambiance musicalement
je n'ai rien contre l'ouverture de
guillaume tell mais franchement si ça
balançait un peu plus et il jouait du
piano debout ça vous ça vous mettra
peut-être un petit peu plus car l
ouvrage
ce sont des petits détails mais c'est
avec ce genre de petits détails qu'on
améliore la qualité d'année passe mes
enfants je vous serai une bonne humeur
et pour être de bonne humeur
rien de tel que de bien manger alors
j'ai l'intention de faire un tour les
cuisines et de goûter un petit peu au
soc flash mob à venir on tombe mois
[Musique]
je fais cuire 125 minutes et c'est
délicieux vraiment le four le thermostat
entre 6 et 8 passes
après sa tâche était pas très bon c'est
pas bon du tout souffert côtoient et
vous mettez un petit peu toi n'est pas
plus parce qu'après tout
et c'est meilleur reichshoffen il
faudrait pas oublier une chose fabriquer
des parapluies
c'est un privilège choisi un sacerdoce
le parapluie c'est un objet sacré ils
nous protègent contre les colère du ciel
fm on perd rendre michonneau et est à ce
titre un bienfaiteur de l'humanité
elle va bien je vous remercie
c'est vrai je ne viendra bien un moment
elle n'est pas bien joué
c'est pas bien j'ai cru je disais je dis
c'est pas parce que et puis maintenant
ça va parce que j'ai fait un peu moi
suzanne michonneau je continuerai
l'oeuvre de papa mon rêve serait
d'ouvrir un parapluie géant au dessus de
vos têtes de vous serrer autour de moi
contre moi dans mon cas j'allais de vous
chouchouter de vous dorloter
parce que vous êtes tous mes enfants une
maman voilà ce que je vais être pour
vous l'innommable
[Applaudissements]
il découvre de mes calculs que la
demande ne parlera plus au pakistan
oriental et de 14% en augmentant nos
ventes de 25% par an nous devrions
obtenir en trois ans 43,7 du marché les
prévisions climatiques à moyen terme
nous permet d'espérer une augmentation
des précipitations passant de 5 m à 8
mètres par an oh la la qu'est-ce qui
flottent la barre et le son de mon père
oui alors si je compte un parapluie pour
trois ménages non a pas rappelés pour
des ménages étant donné qu'ils sont 110
millions d'habitants ça nous fait ça le
fait
[Musique]
ça nous fait 22 millions paie pas ce
malheur du plus noir tout simple école
avec l'article de serre et attention les
japonais sont déjà bien implantés les le
label france est un critère élégance
personne ne peut rivaliser en tout cas
c'est un marché porteur exploiter ou
c'est gentil de mettre tout ça au clair
et d'en faire le résumé à l'attention de
nos ports directeur des ventes bien
madame vous êtes vigneux mopti détenus
travaillé pendant la pause déjeuner
comme ça j'ai pu surveiller ma cuche
elle ne brûle pas au moins un an parce
que j'étais foudroyé j'avais même trouvé
le temps de faire un peu il est
splendide
oui les dahlias du jardin oui comment
vous arrangez vous pour faire 30 choses
à la fois rien faire comme moi une demi
heure de jeu d'une par jour
rien de tel que la journée leur avion à
rignac à leur déjà eu 11 à 10
alors eh ben ils ne voient plus tard et
maintenant j'espère que monsieur pujol
va nous revenir remise à neuf
pas moi votre une cure à fibre ou trois
semaines 2.0 méditerranée ça ils
devraient avoir récupéré un max qui n'a
jamais su se reposer on sait bien pour
ça que j'ai voulu rejoindre la cour par
elano doute qu'elle ait eu assez
d'autorité sur son père il est terrible
vous savez où on me jette
j'aime bien visiter de vous demander de
partir avec lui parce que vous
connaissez bien son caractère ou ne
laissait pas marcher sur les pieds mais
j'avais tellement besoin de l usine sans
vous que serais je devenu l'hymne est
irremplaçable
en tout cas ce qui forçait la gestion
d'entreprise m'avait été d'un secours
une hostie marie fait ce que j'ai pu
j'ai même essayé de mettre en garde
je sais pas ce que le patron pense à de
certaines de vos initiatives au plus tôt
je le sais que trop vous voulez dire la
gratification de part accordée aux plus
anciens ouvriers il ya par exemple
oui moi je crois la participation des
jolies le libéralisme mais vous en
profitez vous êtes beaucoup plus
généreuse que m'offre marié jamais
l'ambiance dans nos ateliers étaient
meilleurs le rythme de production a
sensiblement augmenté ma voix il faut en
convenir
on vous conseille bien qu'est ce qui
vous fait dire ça parce qu'elle est vue
vous inspirer cette nouvelle orientation
niveau des rapports patrons ouvriers le
bon sens mademoiselle manège uniquement
bon sens alors notre mérite on est
d'autant plus grand spa aura pas de
dîner chez des amis hier j'ai cru
percevoir votre voiture qui stationnée
au bord de l'étang et c'est certainement
une erreur foyers ont pu faire et leurs
tuteurs niveau bord de l'étang du
jogging ou de la poésie oui le sport
demande des chiens le prendre mais les
chiens
rien de tel que de ça irait après une
longue journée passée dans un bureau x
et hey les chiens c'étaient les chiens
ça fait du bien et minh tu as bien coup
de choc terrible
bonjour la reine du pop rock ça va bien
assez bien c'est bien hier j'étais à
porter un petit souvenir de dresde qui a
pensé à moi que tu es gentil vous allez
bien elle et y comme quelqu'un qui n'ait
pas pris de vacances et je vous ai
apporté des locaux qui ont tous à bord
mais toujours aussi la suite on dirait
vous attendiez-vous une carte postale un
peu mon bébé je n'avais pas de
secrétaire et grâce à pita aatami j'ai
pensé que ça pourrait servir
j'étais très déçu de ne pas voir nos
aéroports dirige et oblige obligé de
rien tu re annonce une affaire
importante a réduit son frère avait du
boulot boulot moi vous conter les nuits
mais demain soir tueur
tu ne récupèrera le soir tombe avant
mais dis donc je ne vois pas les enfants
maintenant ils sont à la gare dream
usine à la galerie oui s'amuse comme des
fous ils sont faits les tas de petits
copains face à dc arnaud et moi qui
surveille ont tellement notre langage
pour nous ça vous avez que fait coûte
c'est bien simple quand nous disons à
demi mot c'est en anglais et bien comme
ça il sera l'occasion d'apprendre en
français
écrite et jean-charles la galerie
mouvement mais pu être saisie et c'est
vraiment ce qu'on appelle le nivellement
par le bas
qu'est ce que tu entends par le bas le
smig qui frappent acteurs et tendance à
chercher un an et un jour suivant petite
fille on va bien sûr pas ses meilleurs
amis set j'aurais été bonne oui mais en
plus une maison c'est vrai et ça
t'empêche pas me faire habile ça n'est
pas très aristocratique mais nous ne
sommes que les marchands pas plus après
tout moi je sais pas ce que vous avez
mis dans ses valises
ça pèse des tonnes mais le coup n'est
sans doute dit moi tu l'as tu l'as pas
été surpris vois ton fils en europe
alors pourquoi avec les venues
spécialement pour votre retour je trouve
ça très j'entrais temps les prix la
donne des pouvoirs saxe en fait comme ça
une vision si tu étais sous les ors d'un
hangar à bois tu comprends pourquoi j'ai
préféré les langues orientales
bon eh bien je vais récupérer mes petits
loubards la gare on vient d'y donner
tout ce sont là nos merci maman je
préfère rentrer à la maison on va voir
le téléphone raconte j'ai dormirez mieux
ces gens pensent à faire un gracieux
[Musique]
m ancien agostino jamais banal biscuit à
la grand-mère est morte qui sont aller
l'enterrer au portugal oui quand vous du
genre à tout de même décidé marley c'est
comme ça qu'on s'attache les gens à ma
façon de parler ils sont tout le temps
la langue et ça fait rien je vais la
montée ta valise non ailleurs te voilà
sans logistique
une fois de plus je me sens bien quand
je sais pas tout le temps sur le dos
puis j'ai déjà tous les jours à la
cantine trois étoiles c'est très grave
on s'est tapé yara et claude mouton
n'est ce pas mal de sanader j'ai été
obligé de prendre 2 à gaza
j'avais rendez vous avec le médecin du
personnel pour la théorie celle de la
manutention rit elle demande un congé
gros c'est ça oui d'accord mais c'est le
quatrième dans la nuit quand même et
jamais on croise pointé le moindre l'art
d'orphée
nous allons éclaircir ce mystère et
j'espère que l'on verra bientôt
hallucine d'accord je vous fasse mon
rapport
j'ai beaucoup pas vous dire en tout cas
si vous avez besoin de quoi que ce soit
vous savez que je suis à votre entière
disposition
je n'ai jamais renâclé devant les heures
supplémentaires ou est même appelé chez
moi
moi j'aime bien même au sénat dès la
mi-avril uvb connaît bien son affaire 1
s'est donné corps et âme à la couche des
entreprises et oui c'est encore la vie
mais tout en restant très fraîche
je lui ai conseillé d'éclaircir la
couleur chez futuremark na na na na je
te signale la fêlure pompiers au moins
tu sais les compliments je serai bien
bon enfin il en faut de temps en temps
ne serait-ce que pour la bonne marche de
l'entreprise s'est pas tout à fait non
ce n'est pas sur ce point
et bien alors justement ça me force et
je peux te dire que toi mais je sais pas
ce que tu as fait pendant mon absence
mais je te trouve pas mal non en tout
cas mis le cabba le christ que tu
raccroches même pas autour du pot au feu
et bien continuer continue ça te va très
bien
qu'est ce qui t'arrive tu sais que tu
m'en bats les bains pourquoi mais
pourquoi bachir par ton mari tu auras
mis près de trente ans elle aura plus
assez fou ce que je me suis emmerdé
pendant cette fois ci et donc sa jolie
passagère robin joël ne lâchez pas je ne
se mêlent pas les faire de remy pas une
goutte de vin elle maternisé tout mais
tout mais aussi voit-on le résultat
indique montre happy to bronze est
presque un jeune homme s'impose assez
d'énergie alors en faire baver au petit
gars fini aussi pour les vacances
quel gars qui va quand on se les
coulisses et à l'egypte veut dire que
tellement de bien je croyais que
mademoiselle de neige de ce rapport
circonstancié régulière bruyant ben oui
vous êtes est tous mis d'accord pour que
je ne m'inquiète pas au après les durs
moments que nous avons traversées que
des incidents si fâcheuse sur ton est
absente et ça roule bien là bas ça vaut
même très bien
oh oui ça ou même de mu mais toujours à
une hauteur d'assise ont tué 1 6 dans
mon fauteuil que afrique on est abonné
ce que accordé inconsidérément des
augmentations des gratifications et
comment elle considéré meilleur mais je
comprends pas qu'il fallait toute façon
lâcher un peu la pile deux mois ils ont
alors exigé davantage
enfin bon on écoute sur continuer comme
ça alors là on ira l'armée d'accord mais
comment expliques tu adores le chiffre
d'affaires record que nous avons fait le
moine mais non mais non mais non c'est
sur une année entière puisque inclut le
bénéfice en aval à ça veut rien dire là
encore il n'empêche que si nous avons ce
rythme mais chaque actionnaire recevra
des dividendes supérieurs à ceux de
l'année dernière
et si en période de crise alors bombe à
leur écoute tu as été patent alors merci
alors maintenant tu as bien fait joujou
tube arrange étape à l'opinel pdg tu vas
retourner à tes activités familiales et
de récits d'accord non pas d'accord
voilà comment ça pas d'accord on va
confier des responsabilités
à moins de les assumer je sais je veux
et je vais tu m'a remplacé
officiellement comtois ma morale les
trois mois sont passés là bas j'ai
compris je crains qu'il y ait un léger
malentendu entre nous enfin métissé le
patron ici nom de dieu mais moi mais ma
part elle a comme ça y était pour le
vent mais enfin analyse un peu la
situation j'assure la bonne marche de
l'entreprise
j'incarne un patronat souriant ils me
font tous confiance mais pour que
veux-tu te rendre ta place
parce que c'est parce que j'ai le
contrôle de la majorité des actions
voilà pourquoi pauvres d'un qu'il faut
quand même aux acides suissesse je suis
un nazi
j'ai examiné tous à dacia très tortueux
voguer en méditerranée papa malick et
25% des actions ne sais pas j'ai trop
longtemps négligé mais intéressé temps
derniers temps laissant ce soin de gérer
la fortune
et c'est ainsi que thé surmené vouloir
désormais allégé de ce fardeau
je me suis concertée que ma soeur
geneviève qui a hérité comme -2 25% des
actions n'est ce pas elle me laisse
carte blanche et par écrit j'ai les
photocopies à ta disposition dans ce
dossier donc 25 % + 25 %
ça nous fait 50% à main un peu de choses
près ajoute à cela les 10% de laurent
risse et de certains divers petits porte
en effet que personne en contact et qui
m'ont délégué tous les reportages et les
photographes et à ta disposition des
dossiers
ça c'est dont 70% à mon avis tandis que
toi qui dois te contenter de teva % +
éventuelle non les 10% de juin comme tu
le vois le câble au camp est en ma
faveur
le conseil d'administration meta qui de
provisoire
ma position devient définitive et je ne
vois pas je ne vois vraiment pas ce qui
pourrait nous aider l'autre
je ne joue pas bien mais je défendrai
désintérêt communion des mains pour cent
je te les frais ce qui fit et paroles de
femmes
parfois tu as une sérieuse alerte il ne
faut pas l'oublier avait il te faut les
plus gros ménagement pour ça je suis
sérieux tu vas pouvoir vivre avec toi
même tu l'as bien mérité golf chage
monfroy êtes il va pas trop lui gay les
journées paraît trop bien tour tu verras
d'accord ils n'ont pas d'accord pas
d'accord du tout naturellement comme on
n'est pas d'accord c'est pas de quoi il
s'agit mais contrainte d'arrêter de
l'est où mon chéri ton père et moi nous
sommes en train de faire le point ou
alors je ferme la parenthèse je veuille
ou non je dis pas non plus un tel allié
mais je croyais qu'il était venu pour me
voir
ben oui papa je t'ai vu pourquoi tu as
quelque chose à me dire ouais alors tu
sais tu es petite combine avec ta mère
ça va pas se passer comme ça mais quoi
mais quoi vous croyez très fort tous les
deux j'ai pas dit mon dernier mot tout
le temps quand tu voudras pas moi j'ai
toujours été pour le dialogue pour le
dialogue pas pour l'égalité en afrique
orient dont moi
fleurier oui après la petite marquise et
le coma mais c'est à dire toujours ses
dix doigts il va toujours mais il faut
croire oui stephen toujours une molle
pas quand même pas oublier ce que je
t'ai révélait fin juillet il a produit
tout je n'ai toujours sur l'estomac ce
que le savoir oui enfin voyons les
allemands n'en sais rien du tout mais
bon c'est pas majeur elle continue à
faire ils sont frère et soeur mais oui
ouais non ça commence à ses yeux tu sais
tous ces tabous de nos jours mais qu'est
ce que j'entends enfin toi fisam qui a
été élevé chez les soeurs qui appartient
à une génération on en avait encore les
principes
enfin toi c'est respectable justement
pas aussi respectable que tu te plains
fois mais qu'est ce que tu vas me sortir
des choses qui dans un sens vous
rassurer mais dans l'autre mais dans
l'autre ça m'ennuie d'avoir à dire salle
jaune et justement aujourd'hui promets
moi de ne pas être en colère non non je
suis au delà de la colère alors laurent
et floriales peuvent convoler en toute
impunité comme imminent mais puisque je
n'ai agi dans la soirée qu'il ne soit
pas vraiment frère est oui comment
comment serait-ce possible a plus
réfléchi une seconde
tu as la preuve que gisèle marquise et
m'aurait menti
qu'est-ce qui va chier mais c'est
beaucoup plus simple que ça pour gisèle
marquise et non le rang je te crois pas
tu me crois pas mais tu sais que vexant
à la fin j'ai bu un peu tout de suite
moi pour la petite marquise et [ __ ]
mais non c'est pas vrai je ne parviens
pas à y croire et une fée marchiol
c'est une plaque aurait traité morts
leurs tombes et non mais tu m'as
freinant tromper je suis navré mais
cette heure place un petit peu dans le
contexte de faire un petit retour en
arrière
moi j'étais jeune j'étais enfant j'étais
prof je dis vignolles quoi j'étais en
bonne santé je t'ai laissé par un
cavaleur de mari ce qui est arrivé est
arrivé et quand je pense que tu oses et
lui faire des reproches au sujet de
fleurs je t'avais dit que je me vengerai
je me suis vengé mais à l'avant alors la
structure je ne devrais pas ça arrange
tout j'ai réparé son erreur mais avec
qui
allez qui tu m'as trompé c'est mon
secret de la salle palas sonore alors je
le vivais à tant d'égards prescription
ouais je crois pas maintenant pourquoi
alors on ressent aussi prouvé à
saint-palais jolie touche info liette
une explication
oui d'autant que j'ai lu dans un journal
un article très intéressant sur les lois
de l'hérédité veux tu crois que le
million bio rice a salué la fin d'un
article et joël quoi j'aurai ma queue de
ketele salah de toi quand tu peux te
poser la question vraiment je sais plus
quand le doute s'insinue de la confiance
les rassure toi je lis bien ta fille
après la fin d'un ton monte oh t'as des
marches ou encore atteint ici et là ça
c'est légal quand tu fais des surprises
soient ses percées je me rattrape
tu me trouvais tellement pas paul
hembery bah oui mais voilà que le franc
que je préférais peut-être ça j'avais
fini par m'habituer
où est-il enfin où tu écrivais étaient
petits poèmes vie 2 diffuse en effet
plus j'ai changé de style ou à la tour
et plus rien ne m'étonne de toi enfin
pour en revenir à cette vieille histoire
tout j'avais complètement oublié le
corps en voiture tu poses très bien mais
j'aurais gardé pour moi s'il ne
s'agissait du bonheur de ton fils
enfin de laurent
telus a dit mon grand père je te
respecte trop pour ça il n'en saura
jamais rien personne d'ailleurs n'en
aurai jamais rien su même toit si
c'était la fatalité le grain de sable à
les bars et on se croit un homme heureux
et puis tout d'un coup le monde
s'écroule c'est fou ce que tu es et
impressionnable parce que on ne peut
vraiment rien de dirhams
non mais tu sais que champ droit de
demander le divorce et demande le
divorce
jamais tu auras la majorité les actions
toujours aussi sentimental non mais je
le dis dans ce musée
tu sais tu sais ce que tu as fais moi je
viens tu le sais très bien on n'est pas
obligé de le crier sur les toits c'est
tout tu le fais moi-même et l'enclume
mais cesse de pleurer sur toi-même se
côtoient un peu est-ce que je ne suis
pas toujours à tes côtés
tu sais très bien que tu veux compter
sur michel gars très très rare je me
doute de ce que tu dois ressentir je me
mets à ta place
mais tu verras on s'habitue très bien je
suis passé par là moi aussi je trie en
tournée aux usa mais alors là je te
préfère comme ça petit chou c'est pas
tous à la pause déjeuner terminé le
boulot
osama férus de montplaisir te retrouver
on l'a vu barrer un peu avec toi
pour un vieux ménages c'est fou ce qu'on
avait à se dire j'ai fait une quiche
elle est au chaud dans le four j'ai pas
feint même pour ma crise mais un la team
pas bouder
après déjeuner tu montres en attachant
je t'ai fait installer la télévision tu
pourras la regarde et on lit un ya un
film
mieux que ça aujourd'hui madame
au bilan qu'en fait ça en ville en fait
ça me paraît que la nouvelle direction
dire sérieusement à gauche on n'entend
plus que les mots participation
autogestion mais tu n'as pas l'air de 40
groupes et maman est en train de
bousiller d'entreprise bon j'ai départ
moi j'ai donc mon mot à dire et je le
dirai au prochain conseil
d'administration du cje affronter pour
cela madame le président directeur
général puisque tu as l'air d'opter pour
la passivité haut mais je bourre moi je
bous depuis une semaine que nous sommes
rentrés que l'air d'accepter le plus
facilement du monde comptait mis au
rancart on peut voir là comme un
retraité pantouflard tu as d'homicide et
assister les bras croisés à la
dégringolade de la sphère familiale mais
ça fait 30 ans que même en tremblent
devant toi alors c'est clair elle
cherche à prendre sa revanche
elle a été tellement frustré oui alors
là pas si frustré
j'attends quelqu'un qui va sortir par le
jardin oui mais ne me pose pas de
questions il y aura bientôt du nouveau
papa j'étais sûr que tu allais l'ont
prouvé que j'étais toujours le maître
pardon d'avoir de tétouan au jeu me
sophie pujol à nouveau et fier de l'être
mais on pourrait entrer mais je ne vous
espérez cuba j'étais bloqué sur
l'autoroute par une manifestation de
trauma john koller à la une tonnes de
fromage déversé sur la chaussée
avec cette chaleur c'est à dire à plus
riche que vous avez vu ce carambolage
naturellement j'ai été reconnu pour les
objets tirés des banques et de leurs
doléances enfin ce sera environ porte
avez vous êtes débordé je sais aussi
mais j'ai essayé de me retenir le moins
longtemps possible je que ce but on
s'est pris un petit coup de rouge
non merci
sansfaçon or alors monsieur le député je
la loi a pour but vous allé défaire ce
que vous avez fait je ne comprends pas
la grève sauvage l'occupation du sinn ma
destitution enfin madame pujol à la tête
de cette entreprise enfin tout ça tout
ça a été menée le mad men mais rien ne
peut s'opposer à la volonté des masses
populaires et surtout pas c'est vous qui
tire les ficelles
je pense assez logiquement refusé
d'affirmer que seuls les syndicats et la
détermination du souverain lui dis moi
je suis d'abord là dévoile alors bon on
arrête un doublé du maillot d'une autre
même année des crashes une nouvelle
petite crêpe
enfin moi je vais pas vous apprendre
votre métier n'est ce pas pour que je
réintègre mais fonctionne et c'est pour
vous dire au sart et que vous avez
l'outrecuidance de me déranger si votre
conseil d'administration qu'il faut
croire être plus tôt et surtout aux
ouvriers mais cela ça m'étonnerait
qu'ils marchent bien vous êtes amène pas
du tout vous est un manipulateur de
masse alors vous trouve à bien les
arguments
elle porte le projet vaut pour eux de
ces guignols dans l'opposition qui
favorise les pilotes aurait eu 80 des
chevaux
l'autre soir aux bordelais comment
aujourd'hui la semaine précédente dans
ce bistrot de safari ou toujours
accompagné ma femme qui t'ont la
circonstance portait une perruque brune
et vous des lunettes noires vous
dégustez labro shebab la dgi n'y aurait
peut-être n'empêche les faits sont là la
perruque ou si je la retrouvais dans le
placard à chaussures did réelles
questions redonner avouent fouiller dans
les affaires de votre enfant et les noms
au toucher vraiment le froment la vie
d'une y ait entente a fait attendait
ensuite en vous avez aussi toujours en
tête à tête avec mme pujol à la
cafétéria du sofitel dont vérité
j'oppose à cette passation mensongère a
démenti formel je ne devienne méprisant
d'un bris mais pourtant
il ya une photo c'est un monde paris où
tes soucis vous voit les noms vous
voulez une expertise tentative de
chantage du jour de ne pas du tout pas
du tout échange de bons procédés baba
vous tenez absolument à savoir à brias
si c'est possible oui pour truies il est
exact que madame pujol et moi nous
sommes rencontrés voilà en tout bien
tout honneur en coûtait alors voir deux
ou trois reprises pour discuter des
conditions de travail
le bruit afin bien clandestinement
toutes ces précautions la forme pas être
reconnu l aurions évité de faire jaser
mais pourquoi bébé alors pourquoi
puisque vous n'avez rien à cacher parce
qu'elle est une femme à mu marié et
qu'ici en province une certaine société
la vôtre d'ailleurs le domaine tandis
que vos électeurs ne savent pas déranger
le moins du monde si découvrant un beau
matin dans la feuille de chou locale la
photo de l'incorruptible députés en
train de sabrer le champagne avec la
femme de leur patron à paris n'est ce
pas la fin mais je le fais que très cul
à ben oui je ne bois pas et d'ailleurs
c'était le karité l'addition bravo on
ferait bien de rihanna bravo alors je me
suis laissé dire qu'on aimait pas
beaucoup ce genre de publicité dans
votre parti enfin je ne sais pas ce
qu'en pensera le premier thé centrale
tient toujours la tête le secrétaire
général vous savez que non mais moi non
moi votre place non mais je trouve à
l'exclusion mais j'aime à coacher web
je suis prêt à faire mon autocritique
avec à écouter alors on verra bien le
fait pourquoi cherchez-vous à fait un
crétin scandale qui secoue le c'est
comme si tout est ce que je suis un
homme trahi et bafoué et que je me fous
du score a fait toujours un et je vous
jure qu'il ne s'est rien passé entre
autre femme et moi a fait pendant votre
absence d une main non
alors comment expliquez-vous ceux ci
qu'est ce que ce nom mais ouvrez ce
médaillon enfin à je n'y arrive pas là
et ils maladroit le jeu demain
d'ouvriers bon alors là à la voile à
haussimont photo ebrima bun alors je
viens te donne aussi gagnant de femmes
des terres césar oui elle même et non
oui vous avez bien payé la tête à tous
les deux on me medeau mais elle a eu
deux filles
quant à leurs défis tant sa durée votre
petit manège 25 juillet publiés chaque
jour plus crevé oui sur la route
condrieu le diabète secteur alors tu
meures à tout va les canailles mon usine
ma femme mon fils je vous dois de pardon
alors par votre système
oui mais moi ça dit-il étoiles viable de
titres serait-il ils peuvent tous les
gens doutaient pas jusqu'à hier il
paraît que dans ces âmes n'achetait la
tête il était dans l'eau et un bon alors
cette hausse ne peut être que vous droit
monfils
vous croyez sur celui-ci
ça crève les yeux
et pourquoi mon attelle cachée si
longtemps non le relais à l'été tour
étrange destin que la vie les choses
c'est dur c'est vrai pas bon on se croit
même je combattrai endurci et on se
retrouve est papa vous avez de vrais les
purs
oui enfin écouter j'étais pas là et bien
vouloir me faire chanter vous faites du
moins le plus heureux des hommes
voilà alors en tout cas s'il tient qu'à
moi votre carrière politique sera brisée
alors ça ouais oui
l'horreur me reprendre langue d'origine
d'ailleurs vous l'avions pas longtemps
et donnez moi suzanne à mes côtés elle
combattra la cause du peuple donc là je
l'aiderai stabilité lacoste mais elle
redeviendra la petite-fille du
chaudronnier conforme hélas jamais allé
donnez-moi 6 alors bien sûr dépouillé de
tous ses accessoires dont me l'aviez
paraît et qui le flatte et valentin
vanité garder ses chapeaux ses bijoux
ses fourrures
je la veux lui un instant monsieur on ne
dispose pas de suzanne comme ça ouaip
tête eut demandé son avis nous offrait
déjà mais je ne la connais pas si des
noms j'ai dû décommander mon dentiste un
incident inattendu sur la roi les
fromages est couleur pas du tout à pneus
crevés
bon on ne s'en était pas arrivé depuis
vingt cinq ans je sais alors cette fois
je te préviens je ne serai pas l'enfant
mais oublie le recul je suis grand mais
là maintenant c'est toi caire de
l'oublier comment mois pour trouver rim
a tout d'une pâle et des hôpitaux
c'est lui qui va t'aider mais qu'est-ce
que vous êtes dire juste qu'il avait été
ton amant violent il a fallu vous avez
vous inventez vous dégradez qui remonte
à un quart de siècle
bravo jolie mentalité vraiment c'est à
cause de lui d'ailleurs perdu alors
quand on arrive à la vie sous les yeux
latrous a sauté colle à la freedom et
terroirs de mieux en mieux là bas il me
fallait bien faire c'est ton secret
après l'aveu que tu m'as fait moi aussi
je le droit de savoir
oui aurait-il vrai comme en plus on le
prétend que son petit doublé
alors je vous dis regarde comment
trouver sur le nominal orlan comme mon
fils ne sont pas le scooter alors on
dirait que vous avez bien quant à meylan
bonjour mais qu'est ce que c'est que
toutes ces embrouilles liban et non oui
ou non oui l'or et la vérité allait
éclater la vérité
deux seulement attention nouvelle
asseyez vous et je lui ai dit messieurs
pourquoi pas par appuyons papier buvard
on s'en sert une fois qu'ils ont d'être
lesquels de la moder
qu'est-ce que home au chili alors je ne
tenais pas aujourd'hui entré m'a surpris
je vois côté droit qui sont en pleine
discussion excusez moi je fais que
passer au pas si vite je l'homme aux
poteaux de même se serrer mais bonjour
monsieur le député maire
les études la vie vous êtes comprendre
alors il est bien ce personnage
d'ailleurs c'est ça le vrai visage de
notre jeunesse ouvert respire
l'intelligence le courage et plus il a
de plus que ce accueillis par région
avec des biceps comme ça et pourrait
très bien tenir le camion le musée
pourquoi voulez vous je suis un camion
pour rien pour y est à nous avons besoin
des jeunes nous aimons les joueurs je
crois que je vais vous donner l'accolade
c'est trop aimable ouvrir je vous invite
à m'accompagner à la prochaine fête de
l'huma ah oui c'est qu'en septembre
prochain
ah ben voilà le temps oui mon petit
bulletin
on a tout le temps il n'est pourtant pas
en période électorale
par ailleurs lors qu'on nous présente
que floriane accord la noce où je
croyais que tu étais content
ah ben moi je sais je suis plus constant
rien
abbas est nouveau ce avait un vrai avis
il ya beaucoup nouveau dans la maison
on dirait oui mais je t'aime bien par
mail baptiste en ait
tu vois la wii
c'est fou ce que tout le monde est
affectueux aujourd'hui
vous êtes drôles et sommes aussi prompts
à la colère qu'elle attendrissement en
l'occurrence monsieur le député maire
vous vous attendre et c'est un peu trop
vite
j'aurais bien aimé vous faire ce plaisir
désolé il n'est pas importante je vois
pas cela la sphère est assez gras il me
semble pourquoi ne se pêche
attentivement sur les talons voyons je
ne vous ai pas attendu imaginez vous à
vos valeurs finalement il est noir
à quoi rime toutes ces salades désolé en
terre désolée mme en russie n'est ni de
l'un ni de l'autre
bon wilbaux belle alors de qui est il à
l'heure j'ai toutes les raisons de
penser que laurent serait le fils de m
balestra le notaire peut il était co
clair à l'époque inconscient alors lui
aussi de décevants surtout quand on voit
aujourd'hui
j'ai passé de longues heures à son étude
pour régler la succession papa était
jeune il était charmant
il y avait dans son bureau un canapé en
tout 20 ans bravo c'est dupont
enfin conclusion le rat et le fils de m
abalessa tous nos portes à la fois
quoique
quoique si je me fie au salon rassemble
ans il est le portrait craché juré la
toux
mais qui scelle encore celui des très
bien toi tu dois me lever ce soyeux
mylan et que tu as l'invite à une partie
de chasse
ce grand brun qui a braqué away faisait
mouche à tous les coups
intel fait paris
y en a eu beaucoup d'autres comme ça me
rend leur voiture non compris non mais
55 en mai fais ce qu'il te plaît
alors on peut dire que vous allez pas
priver complètement l'info j'ai voulu un
petit os mais vous n'avez le droit de me
suis général une autre petite ce serait
que l'habitude ce que tu faisais pendant
ce temps là la foudre a chambré 6 à la
pâte fans étrangers l'étranger en
haussant ses distances j'ai toujours
attendu machete députés mais rien ne
vous autorise à sanctionner les écarts
de jeunesse voudrait profiter moi-même
je veux placer sur le quai le store et
ben est arrivé en décembre
je n'ai aucune route de mézin
mésaventures ont toujours très brève
très discret nul n'a jamais rien su tout
ça c'est de l'histoire ancienne
j'ai bien d'autres préoccupations
aujourd'hui bon et vos petites soirées
tête à tête pendant la convalescence
ça se terminer comme le plus
sérieusement du monde je te le jure
oui à donne comment voulez vous qu
comprennent non méritants ou alors suisa
il l'appelle suzanne on vous gérez pas
mon vieux à l'essai
poursuivez mon ami il refuse ou aux
boycotteurs
pourquoi pourquoi en coton dans le
médaillon
oui d'habitude aléas tu veux rester seul
avec lui
mais pourquoi tu ne dis pas car elle est
carrément ebadi les a on va couler les
tourtereaux vous vous demandez pourquoi
j'ai gardé votre photo est comme si vous
n'aviez pas compris c'est vrai suzanne
j'ai donc quand un peu pour vous nigo
posède mais si j'avais pu me doutais moi
parce que je peux bien vous le dire
maintenant vous êtes la femme de ma vie
ça vous dérange
je trouve que ces merveilles en temps il
est tombé sur la tête
bon je ne me croyez pas comment
pourrais-je notre aventure a été
sécurisé il y a des minutes qui marque
une existence entière mais vous n'avez
pas une autre aventure
bien sûr j'ai oublié pourquoi aucune
liaison
vous n'avez pas aimé une autre fin non
aux dents voilà qui est bien évidemment
à côté de vos marathon
pardon c'est sale c'est une bouffée de
jalousie introspective votre image anti
minuit j'avais aussi de la chasse et le
relais obsédant je me disais non non tu
n'as pas arrivé tu n'es pas le jouer
dans l'hallucination c'est bien elle
cote a tenu un des bras y est voilà
lendemain je vouvoyais descendre de
votre sim ka sport décapotable un short
blanc une raquette de tennis à la main
inaccessible alors vous passiez la fois
son regard vers moi en riant aux éclats
comme sourire me faisait mal je vous
déteste et je vais vous tuer le
dévouement des mes 20 ans alors suzanne
pourquoi ainsi rejeté pourquoi parce que
j'avais conscience du danger si je me
suis laissé aller à des aventures sans
lendemain
c'était pour tenter de vous oublier
alors oui oui allô oui c'est toi mais tu
n'appelles tu de la cuisine rime
téléphone de la vigie non mais enfin
voyons rambert b peux tu te trompes tu
es bête ou quoi
mettez goûter sont devant toi dans ton
nez 30 comme d'habitude or celui là
alors je vous disais suzanne mais une
formation toute assez mêlé peut-être pas
trop tard mais c'est tout tomber il
refait notre vie avec moi c'est
impossible vous oubliez vous êtes tenus
par une vieille maîtresse famille ce
n'est pas le seul homme politique et
c'est une rivale bien l'exigence
bien sûr je ne relis pas les engagements
que j'ai pris
mais vous savez le vieux militant que je
suis commence à s'essouffler cette
révolution pour laquelle j'ai lutté
toute peu fort
on m'a parfois s'il avait continué à me
bats pour que les générations à venir
presse un monde meilleur
mais moi aussi je dois ma part de
bonheur mais vous la part ou la porte et
réjane bien loin de ce que dis-je de nom
eh bien vous en changez rue
mais comment présenterait voir compagnon
la camarade suzanne exclusion les niches
au no 6 devant pdg j'entends déjà fusé
les quolibets mais mais mais je leur
expliquerai ils accepteront vous aussi
vous êtes éprises de justice de partage
la vie de nos convictions nous verrons
lui rend se lever ensemble de mec qui
chante vous perdriez votre écharpe et
votre siège je suis prêt à prendre le
risque
comme c'est tentant
j'ai l'âme déchirée que les dieux sont
cruels et maudit soit ce jour faut-il
mon cher amour vous quitter pour
toujours en mairie
alors oui oui or chez ton courtois mais
qu'est ce qui ne va pas quoi les gouttes
fois les gouttes
c'est mauvais bonjour loukoum à ses très
bas mettre dans mon genre de haut
c'est ça pouvait lier tout fait alors
vous disiez maurice qu'est ce que je
disais moi c'est moi qui ai dit quelque
chose et vous pariez mais j'écoutais un
français m'en suis jamais depuis trois
mois je ne vis que pour le moment nous
nous retrouvons en cachette comme je les
attendais nous le petit dîner en tête à
tête
nous sommes découverts temps doux comme
je ne parle pas que du brochet beurre
blanc moi aussi je suis bien avec vos
maurice alors elle saisit pour toujours
je ne peux pas ouais le tuer mais non
tout quitter pour vous c'est bien ce
qu'ont demandé les spas moi je ne sais
plus mois avec toutes ses interruptions
il me kazmi une couche savoureux je vous
en prie c'est tout de même mon mari le
père de mes enfants ma fille enfin je ne
vais plus dense avez-vous ne fait pas
une si longue route ensemble sans que se
nouent des liens invisibles sans doute
croyez moi de vous deux c'est lui qui a
le plus besoin de moi suzanne je vous
perd une seconde fois
pourquoi qu'il n'y aura nous voir nous
ferons des petit gueuleton en tête à
tête
nous resterons bronze à lui comme chez
resona c'est le métrage alors adieu soit
vraiment bien vous avez pas positive qui
produit pouvant entrer
vous connaissez je crois monsieur le
député maire monsieur le député maire
vous avez des joueurs importants dire
oui ils sont arrivés j'ai fait entrer
qui ça ces messieurs des actualités
régionales fr3 vous aviez oublié
complètement alors complètement alors je
vous avais trop de choses en tête sans
doute que signifie cette roma le jeu
comprend
10dans vous êtes master en prenant
rendez vous chez le dentiste en même
temps vous convoquer les gens de la
télévision
je vous tour attente il est brouillon
avec monsieur pujol il n'y avait jamais
avec monsieur plus jeune vous vous
arrangez comme vous voulez avec moi
c'est différent
votre job c'est premier rendez vous à
tous en effet et puisque sa part et nous
intéressait particulièrement aux phases
où vous n'auriez pas reconnu c'est avec
monsieur le député maire que je faisais
l'autre soit une promenade digestive au
bordeaux lecteur optique bus ça ne
regarde jamais voulu entendre des jeunes
pas beaucoup les agents doubles
mademoiselle d'âge mais dorénavant je
passais mon service vous êtes une tueuse
archives tellement vous prendrez vos
affaires personnelles et vont joindre
votre poche très bien sait pas ce qu'en
pensera monsieur pujol europe et fait
entrer ces messieurs qui se sert de ces
appareils
j'ai tout de suite bien madame la
patronne n'a pas tardé à relever le
monde font eux mêmes refusent
d'affronter n'importe
vous aviez peur des syndicats français
au nom de qu'on travaille plus je ne
savais pas le moment de le priver de
cette qui passe temps favori alors à
passer ma la bassée mallinger c'est le
téléphone débranché
mais lyon mais quelqu'un refuse à voir
si ça ni avec toi dans la cuisine
très touchant le choix tu as fait merci
sésame
il a tout et goûter quel manque de tact
salle plouc là ça valait la peine et si
j'en ai soutient réal ainsi à dire y
revient je vois qu'il me reste plus qu'à
me retirer le plus jeune mais je vous
rend votre faim à vous être bon et
lusine alors non vous en jouez avec elle
mais pour ce qui est de votre petit coup
de chantage c'est raté où est ben je
trouverai bien autre chose doit
tiens-toi 40 cantons doit toucher des
dividendes avant alors si je comprends
bien alors c'est moi nathan la potiche
en dix ans le prince consort pas vite je
sortirai par derrière la mêlée parce
qu'ils me voyais mais de quoi mais de
quoi s'agit des gens la télévision une
enquête sur les femmes chefs
d'entreprise est un qui me concerne
tu peux te ra soir mais tu veux que je
te dise suzanne et tu commences vraiment
un m'épanouis un passé avec un début mon
bureau le culte de la personnalité dit
que je n'allais pas commencer à
critiquer moi messi et même à vous tirer
dans les pattes à dakhla pdj s'est
taillé une forme d'émission sûrement pas
c'est une déclaration de guerre
c'est une simple mise au point on a fait
des jets auraient eu le plaisir de vous
revoir à mon départ monsieur le député
mmm est super et oui on propose de faire
partie d'une délégation industrielle en
chine populaire à ils ont sûrement
besoin pépin là bas aussi
super pour la chine petite semaine vous
ferai part de mes impressions des
monstres monsieur le député maire
quand vous voilà lancés d'ici que vous
vous présentiez aux prochaines élections
municipales
pourquoi pas non après tout je préfère
me réserver pour les législatives
vous présentez contre moral ça sera
excitant non la politique maintenant et
veut faire les coûts pendant 30 ans je
me suis je me suis contenté de ta maison
il a suffi de trois mois pour remettre
de l'ordre dans son usine
pourquoi ne pas faire la même chose avec
la france c'est une grand partie manque
de femmes de ménage
je suis fait pousser mes manches
s'affermir l'aspirateur à déverser des
flots désinfectant elle regardait de
près le livre de contes
je voudrais tu vois ta maison france le
rebond l'encaustiqué ses placards soit
bien rangée et qu'il y ait toujours des
fleurs fraîches dans les vases une fois
cette tâche encore plus mon vieux
bourgeois sacre à l'euro serait pas la
première
alors vous voyez grand nous avons envoyé
les multinationales où les travailleurs
ayant à un moyen de contenter tout le
monde d'accord pour étendre aux autres
femmes oui appris c'est à quel sujet
balestra voici les statistiques montrent
interview téléphonique syrie oui
permettez moi je vous rappeler que vous
devez assister au baptême de la nouvelle
échelle des pompiers des oui il ya un
réel honneur et à madonna oui j'avais
complètement oublié sans vous que
deviendraient merci je présente pour
nouveau secrétaire yves diba n'est ce
pas monsieur le député maire
messieurs messieurs
balestra le fils du notaire non lui
c'est le petit tu veux mais la troisième
génération rêve tout de suite on kids id
ou encore pascal regard des eaux
mais qu'est ce que vous imaginez ça
n'est pas parce que je vous emmène avec
moi en chine mais vous savez bien je
suis rangé des voitures
robert ne m'attends pas ce soit pour les
dîners il ya dans le frigo en restant de
poulet nourri ce pantalon je dis sans
détour je vous appellerai aussitôt mon
retour bonsoir messieurs bonsoir surtout
soyez bien ça j'ai besoin de bouger de
voir du paysage la vie et à vos fruits y
mord à pleines dents
quel bonheur d'être femme et d'avoir 50
ans je suis bien dans ma peau de renne
et sur la ruche
si potiche je fus je ne serai pas cruche
d'amour
[Musique]